[musique]
Alain Juillet, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Moi, je m'appelle Juliet. Je fais
beaucoup de choses dans ma dans ma vie.
J'ai été militaire,
j'ai été chef d'entreprise, enfin dans
les entreprises puis chef d'entreprise
de l'entreprise françaises et étrangère.
J'ai été au fonctionnaire euh directeur
du renseignement à la DGE puis au
responsable l'intelligence économique
auprès de trois premiers ministres quand
même he ça fait pas mal. Et puis j'ai
été aussi professeur, j'ai donné des
cours dans les universités, je fais des
conférences, je fais de je fais beaucoup
de choses. Voilà.
Il me fait plaisir.
On est très on va se faire plaisir ce
soir. On est très content de vous
recevoir pour la pour te recevoir pour
la dernière.
D'accord.
Surtout on vous voit c'est comme tu
veux. C'est comme vous voulez. On est
très content parce que la dernière fois
que vous êtes passé ou que tu es passé
c'est il y a environ 4 ans.
Ouais.
Donc et la première c'était il y a 7
ans.
Ouais. Et et donc là, on va en pouvoir
on va pouvoir faire un point sur la
géopolitique, la guerre, la guerre
économique, les perspectives pour le
pays, les drones, les survol de MIG, les
couloirs aérien pas respecter,
les ingérences,
il y en a plein plein de choses.
Donc comme c'est la dernière, je je
tiens à confesser à notre communauté que
nous sommes en train de boire du jus de
raisin de Bourgogne et de manger un très
bon saucisson. Donc c'est donc Alain
n'aura le droit que au saucisson et et
nous au niveau jeu de réser et donc
Alain, tu choisis, tu veux commencer par
quoi ?
Ah ben on peut Il y a tellement de
choses à raconter ou à discuter. Euh bah
tu viens, il y a un truc qui m'a amusé
moi, c'était le effectivement les
survols des couloir, les fameux couloirs
aériens là parce que ça c'est ça c'est
pour moi c'est un c'est un c'est là une
fois de plus une démonstration
euh du fait que les gens souvent parlent
de choses qu'ils ne connaissent pas ou
qui comprennent pas.
Quand tu vas pour expliquer he pour pour
nos auditeurs quand tu vas de Russie à
Kaliningrad parce que c'est ça hein, il
y a entre tu vas entrer les pays baltes
au milieu des pays baltes il y a une
avancée qu'elle appelle Kaliningrad la
presquille de Kalingrad et qui
appartient au russe. Donc il y a une
zone qui est russe petite hein mais qui
est russe. Il faut pouvoir y aller. pour
pouvoir y aller. Il y a bien sûr on peut
y aller par des voies terrestres, on
peut y aller par avion. Le problème
c'est quand tu regardes la carte, quand
tu quittes la Russie pour aller vers la
Baltique, tu te retrouves dans la limite
des espaces aériens
de la Finlande et de la Russie. et un
peu d'Estonie, Lituanie
et puis alors et tu arrives ensuite sur
les pays Baltes, il y a tous les pays
Baltes et c'est et c'est c'est collé
avec l'autre limite qui vient de la
Norvège si tu veux et de la Suède. Donc
tu tu as tu en définitive
quand tu es entre la Russie et
Calinrade, tu es exactement à la limite
entre les deux zones aériennes, celle
des Pays-Baltes, des différents pays
baltes et celles des pays de l'autre
côté. Alors si tu fais en définitive
comme tu es juste sur la ligne
d'abord chacun dit "Ah, il va rentrer
chez moi." Bah évidemment qu'il va
rentrer chez toi puisqu'il est sur la
ligne centrale entre les deux, hein. Et
quand tu Et ensuite quand si jamais ils
sortent de de 500 m ou d'un km, on dit
"ça y est, ils sont rentrés dans mes
dans mes dans mes lignes, enfin dans mon
espaces aériens et il va falloir sévir,
c'est complètement ridicule. Ils n'ont
pas de solution autre que passer au
mieux, tu vois. Et bien voilà, moi je
trouve c'est un exemple formidable de la
manipulation des esprits. Mais moi je
dis pas que c'est par mauvaise volonté,
c'est par méconnaissance.
Alors je me fais l'avocat du diable. Euh
euh il y a une petite île en face de la
Lituanie qui est quand même un
territoire lituan et donc la Lituanie
détient l'espace aérien. Mais bon, il y
a il y a pas a il y a pas grand chose
dessus.
Mais
il y a trois amic qui passent. Hm.
Ça les a stressé, ils les ont vu
arriver. Bon, les avions volaient pas
très pas si vite que ça. Ils devaient
être à 900 ou 950 km/h. Euh, ils les ont
vu arriver de loin. Euh les Russes, tu
connais les Russes, les pilotes surtout
les pilotes russes. Moi, pour avoir volé
avec des des pilotes russes de
multigérienne.
Ancien militaire en France, Nana,
c'est show off.
Mais bien sûr,
c'est c'est show off. Il ils volent très
très bien à l'ancienne sur des bonnes
machines bien sûr
mais quand ils peuvent économiser un peu
de gasoile, ils économisent un peu de de
ker
bien sûr ben ils vont le faire c'est
normal.
J'ai j'ai regardé la côté voie ferrée ou
du moins approvisionnement terrestre.
C'est en train en fait de se verrouiller
de l'autre côté aussi. Tant au terme
électrique ou
Oui. Oui.
Alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer si
Calingrade est définitivement enclavé ?
Parce que en terme de de règlement
international, les les Lituaniens sont
de leur pont droit. Ah oui, en théorie
en théorie c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent
tout fermer autour hein et dire de ren
avant on peut plus passer sans une
autorisation préalable hein du pays
traversé. C'est ça peut se faire mais là
il peut il faut toujours passer penser
qu'à ce momentl il peut y avoir aussi
des rétorsions si tu veux. Donc il faut
penser à ça. Si tu es si jamais tu
commences à par exemple à dire bah moi
vous rentrerez pas parce que je bloque
tout. Après, on peut dire "OK, mais
alors vous vous allez avoir des
problèmes ailleurs, hein."
Stratégie classique de guerre froide.
Oui, mais c'est la guerre froide. On
retourne dans le processus de guerre
froide parce que c'est ça la guerre
froide, hein. C'est je te fais un coup,
tu m'en fais un autre et ainsi de suite.
Chacun montrant que montre les dents
mais pas trop quand même parce qu'on
veut pas déclencher la guerre. Donc je
crois que c'est on est dans ce phénomène
là. On est aujourd'hui dans une espèce
dans une guerre froide et une guerre
froide en plus s'encourager par le fait
que
l'OTAN effectivement dit il faut se
préparer à la guerre. Donc hein, alors
que en définition, on vient de le dire,
euh les pilotes qui sont les pilotes des
avions commerciaux qui vont atterrir euh
a priori, ils ont pas des intentions de
de
Là, c'était 3 MIG. Euh
Oui. Alors, mais quand c'est quand c'est
les commerciaux, quand c'est des 3 MIG,
ils viennent sur la zone, ils vont aussi
dans la même zone si tu veux. Alors, tu
as raison de dire "Ouais, mais ils
peuvent jouer dans un sens ou dans un
autre, ils vont faire des manœuvres, ils
font faire des trucs."
Pour les pilotes de chasse he c'est les
pilotes de chasse hein,
c'est des plombiers qui un mange dans la
main, c'est tout.
Ouais. Ouais. Et des pouces bouton, on
pourrait dire pour certains maintenant
avec les technologies des missiles et de
temps en temps, ben ils se font un petit
plaisir, ils se font un petit truc. Bon,
c'est pas
petite ligne droite.
Ouais, mais je pense qu'on a il y a une
aujourd'hui dans ces histoires là, bon
le on monte en épingle si tu veux le
moindre chose hein. On monte en épingle
la moindre chose dans tous les domaines.
Regarde les drones sur les aéroports.
Bon, les aéroports bon ça devient une
obsession maintenant les drones partout.
Alors la question effectivement tu te
dis mais et que certains ont dit oui
mais les drones sont utilisées par nos
les Russes hein pour déstabiliser c'est
pour nous déstabiliser.
Moi je veux bien mais la question que je
pose moi, c'est combien il y a de drones
réellement dont on pense réellement
qu'il pourrait être sous contrôle russe
? Et combien c'est des petits rigolos
qui s'amusent en disant tiens j'ai vu
dans le journal qu'il y avait un truc je
vais envoyer mon petit drone personnel
et qui va se balader et qui va semer la
même panique parce que le drone
personnel ou le droneen on sa on peut
pas les différencier.
Al je me fais l'avocat du diable euh il
y a des étudiants qui ont tracé des des
bateaux dans la région alors que ce soit
des pétroliers
et ils ont vu des manœuvres de bateaux
qui étaient pas très catholiques.
Ah oui oui. pourrait être des
l'équivalent d'un d'un porte-drone. Euh
je sais, ben je sais, il y a il y a les
Français ont arrêté un bateau qui était
soupçonné d'avoir lancé les drones qui
allaient sur l'aéroport de de Munich.
Bon mais là alors là question d'abord
pour aller depuis un bateau jusqu'à
Muni, il y a quand même une certaine
distance he depuis la manche jusqu'à
Munique il y a il en faut de la distance
hein. Donc il faut des pilotes et c'est
un drone déjà d'une bonne taille hein,
c'est pas un petit drone. Donc moi
j'aimerais bien savoir quels sont les
drones la taille réelle des drones qui
sont passés au-dessus de l'aéroport de
Munich. Bon et la deuxième question
c'est mais là c'est tout bête mais une
technique hein c'est que il faut savoir
quand même que en en manche il y a
beaucoup de vent hein c'est un couloir
et il y a beaucoup de vent les drones ne
peuvent pas voler
au-dessus d'une certaine vitesse de vent
parce qu'ils sont pas stabl pas
suffisamment stables, sauf les très gros
drones. on revient en gros drone. Donc
ça veut dire que il faudrait se poser la
question est-ce qu'on est sûr que les
conditions météo étaient réellement pas
trop fi forte et à ce moment-là que
effectivement des drones pouvaient
décoller et quelle était la taille des
drones ? Tu vois, il y a des questions à
se poser. À partir du moment, on a les
réponses. Là, on peut commencer à
réfléchir en disant "Ouais, ça c'est ça
pourrait être un drone de longue de de
vol de longue durée, mais un drone fait
pas 400 km, 300 400 ou 500 km comme ça
si tu veux." C'est pas
la question que je me pose en terme de
renseignement. Oui,
parce qu'on va mettre de côté le côté,
on va vous faire perdre 100 millions de
dollars parce que on a on a fait fermer
votre aérodrome
ou ça vous déstabilise, ça vous stresse.
En terme de renseignement, c'est quoi
l'intérêt de faire voler un drone près
des d'un aéroport ? C'est repérer où
est-ce qu'il faut taper ? C'est juste
pour un aéroport. parce qu'on a les
plans. Tous les aéroports du monde, on a
les plans puisque tu as les pilotes
quand il quand ils décollent et qui vont
aller dans un aéroport, ils ont le plan
ils ont un plan sur leur ordinateur de
bord, ils ont le plan en papier donc on
sait on connaît tout sur les aéroports.
On n pas besoin d'avoir un drone pour
survoler. Tout ce à quoi ça peut servir
? uniquement à gêner la circulation
aérienne parce que c'est vrai que si tu
as un drone qui se balade à 10, 20 ou 50
m au-dessus des pistes, un avion qui
atterrit ou un avion qui décolle, s'il
le prend dans un moteur, ça peut causer
un vrai problème, hein. C'est pire
qu'un, tu sais, c'est le problème dans
les aéroports, on a les oiseaux qui
posent des problèmes, hein. Alors, on
essaie de les chasser les oiseaux avec
des appareils, avec des fonctions, avec
il y a tout, hein, pour les chacun
trouver des solutions pour faire partir
les oiseaux. Parce que si un avion un
red un jet surtout prend des des des
avions dans un ré pardon des Oui. des
oiseaux dans son moteur, il se crache.
Ouais. Ou il finit sur un seul
ou alors il a un gros problème si tu
veux. Donc on veut éviter ça. Alors s'il
se prenait exactement pareil si à la
place de l'oiseau il se prenait un
drone. Donc le drone représente un
danger. Ça c'est exact.
Mais mais il faut pas non plus
transformer.
Alors je me fais je me fais l'avocat du
diable
bien sûr.
Je me dis "OK, mettons-nous dans la peau
de Popofov premier. Je vais faire voler
des drones parce que mes satellites ont
pas une si bonne résolution que ça. Je
veux repérer s'il y a pas des avions de
chasse qui sont peut-être stationnés ou
des dispositifs". Alors là, alors là
aujourd'hui, tu as tu as vu dans la
guerre en Ukraine, les satellites nous
donnent maintenant des images où on voit
les gens qui progressent, hein, les
satellites commerciaux hein, les
satellites commerciaux donnent des
images où tu vois les gens qui sont en
train de marcher, les combattants qui
sont en train d'avancer et qui montrent
un drapeau drapeau russe, drapeau
ukrainien selon le cas et parce que
c'est maintenant c'est la mode hein pour
montrer qu'on est arrivé quelque part.
Bon le quand tu à partir du moment où
ils sont capables de voir un petit
bonhomme, autant te dire que les avions
de chasse, les services de renseignement
et les satellites militaires, eux ils
voi tout hein. Tu sais, un satellite
militaire aujourd'hui, il est capable de
lire une plaque d'immatriculation de
véhicule. C'est ça qu'il faut voir.
C'est ça la taille actuelle, hein. Il
voit la là, tu te rends compte, ils
arrivent à lire une plaque
d'immatriculation. Donc autant te dire
que ils ont les si jamais il y a des
avions sur un a dans un aéroport, ils
connaissent tous les types d'avions. Les
analyse se dire "Ah bah oui, ça c'est un
ça ça c'est ça, ça c'est ça." Ils savent
tout. Donc si tu veux, c'est pas la
peine.
On élargira le sujet des des objets
volant identifiés sur la fin et le
rapport cométa et tout un tas de trucs
parce que j'ai une grande partie de ma
communauté qui m'a demandé
d'avoir un regard critique là-dessus.
Oui, je peux t'en parler. Je peux t'en
parler. Je bien le sujet. Ouais.
Après la divulgation par la la marine
américaine de cette
absolument du limite. Les images du
limite. Oui.
Donc on en parlera sur la fin de de
l'interview. Là on va on va continuer
sur le conflit ukrainien et la
géopolitique.
On a vu notre chef d'étatmajor Cocorico
est un lanceur d'alerte concernant les
menaces et la force d'âme que nos
enfants et les familles de nos enfants
devront avoir un peu plus tard. Oui.
Ouais.
Ensuite, on a vu le chef allemand et
ensuite on a vu le chef anglais,
l'équivalent de notre chef d'étatmajor.
Quelle est ta lecture ? Pourquoi il y a
réellement une menace ? Il y a pas de
menace ? Ils ont besoin de faire un
budget, ils ont besoin de préparer les
peuples, ils ont besoin de redresser
leur économie, ils ont besoin de se
préparer ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
possibilités d'explication.
Remets ton micro parce que j'ai mon
ingénieur du son qui est en train de de
raller
bien là.
Attends, remets-moi, remets-moi. Je vais
faire je vais faire la spre. Non,
attends, attends.
Non, non, vas-y, je vais meubler. Donc
c'est préparer un budget, c'est préparer
les opinions, c'est masquer un
effondrement économique ou c'est ou
c'est se préparer réellement un carton
avec les Russes.
Alors
le premier problème d'abord qu'il faut
bien voir, c'est que la guerre en
Ukraine
a complètement changé notre vision de la
guerre moderne.
La guerre des drones. Alors là, on parle
des drones militaires. L'utilisation des
drones dans le casadre des militaires a
bouleversé toutes les approches puisque
il a fallu qu'on invente de nouveaux
systèmes.
On peut plus progresser pendant pour les
sections danserie hein. Tuas tu peux pas
faire marcher à 30 bonhommes quelque
part parce que tu as les drones
arrivent, te balancent des grenades et
tout le monde est éliminé. Maintenant
c'est des tout petits, tu progresses
dans le combat moderne avec des tout
petits groupes et de préférence avec des
moyens mobiles hein. Les quads, les
motos. tu es deux sur une moto ou un
quad, tu vas à 60 à l'heure, là le là le
drone il peut pas t'avoir et tu vas
faire quelque chose à 2 km et tu
reviens. Enfin, c'est n'a plus rien à
voir avec les progressions, les
techniques du passé.
Pareil pour les regarde pour les chars.
Bon, on a appris un peu maintenant mais
il a fallu qu'on apprenne à protéger les
chars par au-dessus parce que une une à
l'époque une grenade qui arrivait sur le
toit et du char était foutu. Alors
maintenant on a on a commencé à changer
le système. Donc on a tout modifié. Bon
le problème c'est qu'ils ont tout
modifié là-bas. Les Russes se sont
adaptés,
ont modifié tout leur équip leurs
équipements. Les Ukrainiens, bah là
aussi,
mais nous, nos armées à nous, elles sont
absolument pas préparées à ce type de
guerre. Mais alors absolument pas hein.
Mais
si les Ukrains sont capables de se
préparer, je vais direous les Français
quand même. Cocor que
eux ils sont ils se battaient et qu'au
fur à mesure de la guerre ils ont su
évoluer si tu veux hein. Et mais on leur
a fourni des matériels, on leur a fourni
des drones, on leur a fourni, ils ont
acheté du matériel, on leur en a fourni,
on a envoyé, il y a plein de choses qui
ont été qui ont été données aux
Ukrainiens et quand tu regardes nous
dans notre armée, on les a pas, tu vois,
ou alors on a autre chose et on
s'aperçoit qu'il va falloir changer. Ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'il faut
repenser complètement le format de nos
notre armée pour la rendre capable de
tenir dans une condition comme en
Ukraine. Il faut changer le format de
l'armée et pour ça, il va falloir
investir dans des moyens supplémentaires
dans plein de domaines. Bon, alors ça se
fait pas en 15 jours hein. Le le le
général Leoin, le chef d'étatmajor le
grand chancelier ou Puga qui a été grand
chancelier ou encore ville de Viliers.
ancien chef major armé tous disent la
même chose. Tous disent attention il
nous va valoir 5 à 10 ans vu l'état de
l'armée française pour pouvoir la
transformer. Alors la question c'est
comment dans un pays comme le nôtre on
peut transformer
investir si veux pendant 5 ans ou 10 ans
dans la défense alors qu'on a plus
d'argent ? Oui, parce qu'on a pas
d'argent en plus. Tu un pays qui a pas
d'argent la France. Donc la réponse il
va falloir du temps, il va falloir de
gros moyen et il va falloir pour ça
convaincre les Français que c'est
prioritaire d'investir dans la défense.
Alors comment on fait ? Bah on va leur
dire les gars, on a une armée qui va pas
bien, il faut qu'on la réforme, ça va
prendre 10 ans. Ça marche pas. Surtout
les gens diront il y a d'autres
priorités. Si tu leur dis demain risque
d'avoir la guerre, on dit là quand même,
il faudrait peut-être quand même qu'on
soit capable de répondre. Donc si tu
veux, c'est un calcul pour moi hein,
aussi bien pour les Anglais que les ont
la même situation hein, les Anglais, les
Allemands et les Français, la première
raison c'est
trouver les moyens financiers pour avec
l'acceptation du public hein des nos
concitoyens pour avoir modernisé plutôt
une armée et la moderniser dans un délai
assez raisonnable. Bon, pour qu'on
puisse ensuite faire face à un conflit
éventuel. Alors, ça c'est le premier
point, mais c'est très important parce
que c'est le fond du problème. Parce que
aujourd'hui, si tu veux quand on te dit
"Oui, mais on va faire la guerre
là-haut",
c'est pas vrai. Puisque
les
Trump et Poutine ont on sont mis
d'accord avec Zelenski là. cette
fois-ci, il a donné l'accord de jours ou
3 jours. Il a dit je suis d'accord pour
qu'il n'y ait pas l'OTAN en Ukraine.
Mais pas l'OTAN en Ukraine pas une armée
européenne en Ukraine.
Donc on ne peut plus rentrer en Ukraine.
Donc on peut plus faire la guerre
directement. C'est ça qu'il faut que
j'ai regardé.
Il a dit pas pas l'OTAN en Ukraine où
l'Ukraine n'intgr n'intégrera pas
l'OTAN.
Oui, mais c'est la même chose si tu
veux. À partir du moment où l'Ukraine n
n'a pas intégré l'OTAN, et bien l'OTAN
peut pas aller en Ukraine. On peut avoir
des observateurs, mais on peut pas
envoyer et on peut pas envoyer les
armées de l'OTAN, c'est impossible.
Alors en plus, on sait que les Russes
veulent pas entendre parler. Donc ça
veut dire que nos armées ne peuvent pas
aller faire la guerre. Nos armées, elles
vont être au ce qui se passera à mon
avis parce qu'on y va.
R
on va les mettre oui prépositionn comme
on dit dans les pays limitrophes de la
Pologne à la Roumanie si tu veux tout le
long hein. On va prépositionner des
militaires de manière à ce que si les
Russes avaient l'envie d'attaquer
le reste de l'Ukraine parce que d'abord
avant d'aller ailleurs, il faut d'abord
qu'il qu'ils attaquent le reste de
l'Ukraine ou les fameux pays baltes
puisque tout le monde parle des pays
baltes à ce moment-là on serait sur
place pour répliquer immédiatement.
Mais j'ajouterai si tu veux parce que
c'est important hein, il y a une
commission du Sénat qui a fait une
enquête sur la l'armée française en la
question et si l'armée française était
en Ukraine, elle ben le constat c'est
elle tiendrait 6 jours et sur un front
de 80 km alors que le front ukrainien il
est de plus de il dépasse les 1000 km on
tiendrait 80 km par après il y a plus
d'armée c'est là où tu vois qu'il faut
qu'on réforme tout hein et qu'évidemment
Ça pose un vrai problème.
Oui, mais c'est Ouais. Remets ton micro
pendant que je parle. Euh
c'est c'est 80 km mais c'est des beaux
kilomètres. C'est des kilomètres
français avec les bonnes rations de
combat, les genre 6 jours tranquilles
genre français avec des canadon César,
Cocorico. Bon, c'est très bien. Voir le
chef des le chef des armées, Emmanuel
Macron, se balader dans des centres
d'apprentissage ou des collèges ou des
écoles où on voit des gamins d'une
vingtaine d'années, pas des collèges,
des préparer sa ration de combat.
Ouais. Toi en tant qu'ancien militaire,
ça te fait plaisir, pas plaisir, tu dis
que c'est bien, ça fait de la pomme de
[__] pour l'armée, ça va faciliter le
recrutement.
Non, moi d'abord il y a tu il y a une
chose, je pense alors moi je je là c'est
pas du c'est pas vraiment c'est une
critique quand même sans être une
critique si tu veux. Moi je pense que le
chef d'étatmajor c'est mal exprimé.
D'abord,
tu ne dis pas où que ce soit quand tu es
militaire, tu dis pas à tes gars les
gars, on va partir et vous allez tous
être tués.
Il a pas dit ça.
Non mais tant que il a dit les petits
français, vous allez perdre, vous allez
dire "On va tuer des petits français.
Euh, excuse-moi, c'est quoi ça ?" Tu
peux pas dire ça. Tu peux dire si il
faut quand même voir les choses pour que
les gens aient le moral et puis il faut
leur dire "On va gagner."
Donc tu leur dis ça va être très dur, il
va y avoir de la casse mais on va gagner
parce que on te donne les moyens de
gagner. Alors là d'accord et pour se
donner les moyens de gagner il faut
qu'on investisse tout à fait d'accord.
Et là il a raison là il a totalement
raison mais si tu veux la présentation
elle été fait de telle manière que c'est
pas ça se fait pas comme ça.
Je vais je vais défendre notre semma. Tu
me connais les les verts les verts je
les défends à chaque fois. Mais oui,
il y a le chef d'étatmajor allemand et
anglais, ils ont dit sensiblement les
mêmes mots.
Oui, mais tu sais, tu as quand tu quand
le problème c'est qu'on les on les voit
les chefs d'étatmajor jusqu'à
maintenant, je sais dans les armées.
Bon, à chaque fois, il réclamait des
budgets supplémentaires, des moyens
supplémentaires pour faire le
porte-avion, les avions tout ça. Enfin,
chaque fois c'est pareil. Bon, et ça
c'était la la le système normal. Mais il
faut bien dire que depuis 30 ans, on a
l'armée française, on l'a réduit chaque
année. On a réduit les dépenses chaque
année. On on nous mentait si tu veux
parce queon nous disait par exemple que
la la défense, me souviens à 2 3 ans, on
disait la défense cétait plus de 3 %.
C'est pas vrai du tout. La défense elle
était en dessous de 2 % elle était et là
l'année dernière elle était à 1,68 % du
PIB. C'est pas 3 %. Et quand tu penses
qu'à l'époque de l'Algérie ou de ou du
l'Indochine, on était à plus de 5 %,
hein. Bon là, on était on était à 1,68
%. Alors, comment on fait la différence
? C'est que entre 1,68 % et 3 % ou 2 et
c'était les retraites. On incluait les
retraites pour dire il y a un gros
budget de défense. Mais tu peux pas dire
quoi ? Les retraite, c'est la défense.
Et tu peux pas dire que l'éducation, du
moins la retraite dans l'éducation c'est
l'éducation.
Mais oui, exactement. Mais c'est pareil.
C'est pareil. Donc si tu veux, c'est une
présentation pas très claire hein, pas
très mais qui veut cacher une réalité,
c'est quand quand Donald Trump dit "Si
vous voulez faire face au Russes, il
faut 5 % du PIB, il a raison.
Mais qui est prêt à mettre 5 % du PIB ?
Il y a que les Polonais.
Mais pourquoi ? parce que les Polonais,
ils sont en première ligne, ils sont
là-haut et puis eux ils connaissent
parce que eux, ils ont été envahis hein
par les Russes et ils ont passé 40 ans
sous par les communistes,
par les communistes, par les communistes
et ils ont passé 40 ans sous le régime
communiste dans l'Union Soviétique.
Alors il veut pas que ça recommence.
Alors eux ils investissent en priorité
et c'est là où ils investissent 5 %.
Quel est quel quel serait l'intérêt de
de Poutine ou de son gouvernement ou de
des mecs qu'il y a derrière d'aller
envahir l'OTAN ou d'aller
mettre une punition au pays Balt ?
Mais aucun
c'est pas reculer une zone tampon, c'est
pas mettre à distance. Il faut il faut
se souvenir alors il faut se souvenir de
ce qui de comment ça s'est passé hein.
Maintenant on connaît on connaît bien
parce que les Américains surtout ont
travaillé là-dessus beaucoup plus que
les Français ou les journalistes
français hein.
En en en 90-92 quand il y a eu les
négociations entre Gorbachov d'un côté
pour l'Union Soviétique et James Becker
pour les Américains. On sait maintenant
parce qu'on les a retrouvé he les textes
ils sont à l'université George
Washington euh aux États-Unis. dans les
archives de l'université,
on a retrouvé les textes des
compte-rendus de discussion entre Becker
et Gorbatchov où Gorbatchov lui dit "Je
suis en gros je résume hein, je suis
d'accord pour ouvrir les frontières mais
en contrepartie vous nous promettez que
jamais l'OTAN ne viendra dans les pays
limitrophes de l'Union soviétique de la
Russie pardon les pays limitrophes donc
les pays balt la pous ces pays-là pas
question que vous rentriez dans ces
pays-là Bon, ça c'est nous sommes dans
les années 90. Bon, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Comme tu sais, ça tient pas. On
les pays bal puis la Pologne puis la
enfin tous ces pays, la Hongrie, la
Roumanie, tous les pays rentrent dans le
système rentrent dans l'OTAN. Donc, on
respecte absolument pas les accords qui
ont été passés.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Les Polonais, ils ont droit d'avoir un
esprit
à aller à une autodétermination vers la
liberté.
Ah mais je suis d'accord. Ah mais il du
point de vue des p Mais si tu veux du
point de vue des pays hein. Du point de
vue des pays, bah bien sûr, ils avaient
tous le droit de dire e on vient de
passer 40 ans sous le jug soviétique,
vous allez quand même nous laisser libre
de faire ce qu'on veut. Et ils ont pas
tort. Ils avaient pas tort. Mais
l'accord, si tu veux qui avait été passé
entre les Américains et les Russes
disait "Dans cette zone-là, c'est une
zone neutre." Ça veut pas dire
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait pas une armée
locale. Zone neutre, ça veut dire que
les l'OTAN ne rentrait pas dans cette
zone-là pour faire pencher du côté
occidental. Bon, très bien. Qu'est-ce
que Poutine a dit ? En 2007 à la
conférence de Munich, à la conférence
sur la sécurité de Munich, Poutine il a
dit "Vous nous avez roulé dans la
farine." En gros, je résume, mais c'est
le texte, on le retrouve, il est
officiel hein. Vous nous avez roulé dans
la farine parce que vous avez pas tenu
les engagements qui avaient été négociés
avec Gbatchov. Mais moi je vous dis
attention, il y a trois pays sur lequels
vous ne devez pas toucher et je le
laisserai pas, c'est la Biélorussie, la
Geéorgie et l'Ukraine. Là, il a dit, il
a dit là vous ne rentrez pas parce que
ça c'est stratégique pour nous. C'est
bon, on y truche pas. Et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ? Et ben on s'aperçoit qu'à
partir de 2009-2010
bon on avait commencé sur l'Ukraine
avant, on a fait la révolution orange.
C'est quand même Sose qui a fait la
révolution orange, qui organisé la
révolution orange.
C'est quoi les sources
hein ?
C'est quoi les sources sur la révolution
?
Ah bah c'est simple hein, c'est que
toutes les révolutions oranges qui ont
été faites dans les pays de l'ancien
bloc soviétique hein était toute avec un
foulard orange qui avait été acheté en
Chine. Ça c'est amusant. Les foulards
avaient été achetés en Chine et ceux qui
avaient financé c'était une des une des
sociétés de Soros. Donc on peut dire que
Soros a financé la révolution. S'il a
financé les foulards, il y avait
d'autres choses aussi. Mais avec
l'accord bien sûr de l'Amérique hein,
tout le monde était d'accord pour que il
y a C'est clair. Bon, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé derrière ? Ils ont eu les
Européens, les occidentaux. On a poussé
en Ukraine, on a poussé des dirigeants
proeuropéens comme Timochenko, Julia
Timchenko. Bon,
on a on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu pour
les ramener vers nous. Et puis et c'est
ça qui est c'est là où ça il y a eu le
le clash d'ailleurs c'est quand à un
moment il y a eu les les Européens et à
l'époque c'était Baroso hein le patron
de la Commission européenne a dit aux
Ukrainiens il faut signer un accord
commercial d'échange avec les Européens
et les Russes ont dit mais non il faut
vous signer avec les Russes alors les
Ukrainiens de l'époque hein on cherche
on regardait les deux et on et on
décidait que le meilleur accord pour
eux, c'était avec les Russes et c'est
juste après cette décision qu' a
commencé les troubles de la place
Maidane.
Tu vois
le hasard
le hasard ça a commencé juste après le à
la fin de la place Maidan.
C'était quelle année ça
hein ?
C'était quelle année ? C'est l'année où
il y avait
2012 2012 je pense.
C'est l'année où il y avait Victoria et
et John Mcken qui distribuait des petits
pains.
Ah mais il y avait plein de choses à la
place Maidan. Il y a eu plein de choses.
C'était la place Maidan si tu veux.
C'est je crois que c'est c'est les
Américains qui ont dit qu'on a ils
avaient financé c'est Victorien hein la
ambassadrice à l'OTAN ambassadrice
américaine à l'OTAN qui ensuite a été
vice député vice-ministre des affaires
étrangères américaines sous Biden donc
c'est pas rien quand même et qui est la
femme d'un chef néoconservateur qui
s'appelle Kagan et Vital a dit au
congrès américain c'était de ou 3 mois
après le début de la guerre en Ukraine,
elle a été auditionnée au Congrès
américain et donc il y a les textes là
le dit et elle dit "Écoutez, on a
investi 5 milliards de dollars pour
faire basculer l'Ukraine du côté
européen. On n'allait pas tout perdre
hein, il fallait qu'on fasse bouger les
choses." C'est clair. Elle a dit puis de
tout de bonne foi de son de son point de
vue.
Et mais si tu veux, ce qui est
intéressant c'est que donc à la fin de
la place, je sais qu'à la fin de la
place Maidan, il s'est passé comme sur
la place Tarir Tarir en Égypte à
l'époque de la révolution contre le
frère musulman.
Tamam,
pareil.
hein.
Tamam.
Ouais. Et bien, ils ont ils ont tiré, il
y a eu des coups de fusil qui sont
partis qui ont blessé des manifestants
qui en ont même tué. Donc à la place
Maidane, bah la foule est devenue au
furieuse comme à la place Taria, elle a
attaqué les bâtiments gouvernementaux.
C'est classique, hein. Bon, ils ont
renversé le président, on a mis à ce
momentlà, on a mis un nouveau président
et comme par hasard, il a signé l'accord
commercial avec les Européens alors que
le précédent et avec l'appui de la
majorité de la population avait dit on
choisira l'appui des du parlement, hein.
Ils avaient dit on choisira les Russes.
Donc si tu veux, c'est ça, il faut bien
comprendre tout ça parce que c'est un
d'enchaînement si tu veux. Euh tout ça
pour dire parce que par rapport à ta
question, on est dans cette affaire-là
au début hein, on est dans le début de
l'affaire. Après, il y a plein de
choses, mais au début de l'affaire, il
est très clair que pour les Russes, on
ne touche pas à la zone limite. Et nous,
les Européens, les Français, c'est
intéressant aussi, c'est que jusqu'à ce
moment-là, nous, on a aucune envie de
faire la de faire la guerre, de monter
là-haut. On n pas envie, hein. On dit
"Oh là là Puis en plus l'Ukraine a pas
une bonne réputation encore à l'époque
hein, c'est moins qu'on puisse dire.
Donc il y a le les Français ils sont
très prudents. Ils disent non, il faut
essayer de trouver des solutions
consensuelles, il faut calmer le jeu, tu
vois. Il y a hein et puis et puis après
ça va dériver comme on connaît.
On va revenir sur les questions de
préparation de guerre des occidentaux et
des Européens. Juste après euh
là maintenant, on voit des accords de
paix. Les Européens sont pas à la table.
Les Européens font un peu comme des
gamins à Noël sur la petite table dans
la cuisine. C'est-à-dire, ils font un
peu de bruit, ils disent "Voilà, venez à
notre table, venez à not table, on
s'ennuie." Ou ils veulent s'incruster à
la table des grands.
Oui.
Quand on dit "Vous n'êtes pas à la
table, c'est que vous êtes forcément au
menu." Ça les stresse. Pourquoi les
Européens sont pas à la table des
négociations ? parce que c'était une
guerre par proxy et que là on voit
réellement les vrais Belgi
ils ont leur strat si je veux
stratégiquement parlant
les trois les trois principaux européens
les Allemands les français les anglais
ont fait un choix qui est diamétralement
opposé de celui des Américains.
Or cette guerre il faut quand même pas
l'oublier cette guerre elle a été
démarrée avec la puie des Américains.
Les Français, ils étaient pas dedans.
Les Allemands non plus, les Anglais non
plus. Les Anglais si parce qu'ils
aidaient ils aidaient l'armée à l'époque
mais les autres étaient pas. Les
Américains ont fait la mal à l'époque de
Biden, hein, ils ont fait tout ce qu'il
fallait. Bon, ils sont ils se sont
retrouvés dans cette guerre. Bien
maintenant, ils veulent les Américains
veulent arrêter la guerre en disant
pourquoi ? parce qu'ils se sont rendus
compte enfin c'est le nouveau président
Trump s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
poussé les Chinois vers la pardon les
Russes vers la vers la Chine et que
c'était catastrophique
parce que si les Américains font la
guerre, il faut le savoir, c'est ça
l'histoire, si les Américains font la
guerre à la Chine, le général Miley,
commandant chef d'étatmajor américain à
l'époque de Biden qui avait été et du
premier mandat de Trump, on lui avait
demandé
Est-ce que la en cas de guerre contre la
Chine, est-ce qu'on peut gagner ?
Réponse : Mais on aura des pertes
colossales. Ce sera la guerre nucléaire
quand même. On aura des pertes
colossales et l'Amérique en sortira
affaibli. Bon, après, on lui avait dit
mais la Chine c'est bien, mais si c'est
la Chine et la Russie plus la Russie,
donc il y a deux fronts si tu veux. le
front européen, je dirais le front
asiatique. La mail avait répondu : "Nous
neons pas la capacité avec notre armée
d'avoir deux fronts à la fois et de
pouvoir gagner." C'est clair, ça a été
dit et écrit par les Américains. Bon,
alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a tiré Trump comme
conclusion ? les deux d'ailleurs Biden
d'abord puis Trump ensuite. Biden a dit
puisque c'est comme ça, il faut
affaiblir la Russie pour que elle ait
plus de capacité de s'opposer à nous si
on fait la guerre à la Chine qu'elle
soit vraiment très affaiblie. D'où
l'idée, on rentre dans l'Ukraine et on
déstabilise complètement la Russie. On
l'épuise
deux manières. On épuise son armée face
à l'armée ukrainienne en donnant à
l'armée ukrainienne les moyens d'écraser
l'armée russe et par les sanctions
économiques, on tue l'économie russe.
C'était ça le plan Biden. Bon, c'est un
échec total, il faut bien le dire. Ça,
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire. Après
est arrivé Trump qui dit "C'est pas ça
du tout la solution. La solution, vous
avez fait une erreur, c'est on va
ramener la Russie vers nous."
Bon courage,
c'est Trump. Ouais, mais bon courage.
Ah oui, mais attends. Et il dit, on va
ramener la Russie. Comment on va faire ?
On va faire la paix en Ukraine. On va
leur faire dans la paix en Ukraine, on
va lâcher certains trucs qu'ils veulent
de manière à leur montrer qu'on les aime
bien et on va développer des relations
économiques entre la Russie et les
États-Unis. On va créer un tel ça sera
tellement intéressant si tu veux que les
Russes ils diront "Bon, c'est les
Chinois c'est bien mais l'Amérique c'est
mieux". Ça c'est le calcul de Trump,
c'est ça qui joue hein. Bon et dans ce
cadre là, il veut faire la paix en
Ukraine et une paix si tu veux
équilibré. Et il a déjà annoncé, il
l'avait dit après l'Alaska, mais c'est
parce que dans l'Alaska, ils se sont mis
d'accord entre les deux, hein. Ils a
déjà annoncé que dès que la paix sera
arrivée, il lèverait les sanctions.
Entre parenthèses, lui va lever les
sanctions et nous les Européens,
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? Enfin, ça
c'est autre chose. Alors, c'était pour
dire voilà le schéma si tu alors les
Européens qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait au
départ ? Ils étaient pas dans le coup.
Après, les Américains de Biden leur ont
dit, il faut quand même que vous
interveniez, que vous fassiez que vous
nous aidiez à financer, hein. Alors, il
y a les sanctions, vous allez faire les
sanctions et on voit que les sanctions,
ça nous est coûté plus à nous que ça n'a
coûté aux Russes. Ça a pas marché les
sanctions, c'est vrai hein. Mais
derrière, il y a un deuxième truc. On a
dit vous allez aider la l'Ukraine avec
de l'argent, avec des moyens, avec bon
plein de choses. Ce qu'on a fait.
Le problème c'est que quand Trump a dit
mais on va créer on va réattirer la
Russie vers nous créer des liens avec la
Russie les trois Européens ont dit mais
pas du tout il faut que la Russie ça
soit le bloc le porc épique le hérisson
si tu veux européen qu'on a mis là-haut
et qui va gêner les Russes et qui les
coince et il faut qu'on l'aide sur il
faut qu'on donc qu'on aide la R la
l'Ukraine sur le plan militaire donc
c'est exactement à l'opposé
Si tu veux de la position américaine,
c'est ça qui est le problème. Alors bien
sûr, ben quand les Américains négocient
avec les Ukrainiens et avec les Russes,
pourquoi tu veux qu'ils appellent des
gens qui pensent exactement le contraire
d'eux ? Tu c'est ça le PR. Donc bien sûr
qu'on n'est pas invité. Alors d'un autre
côté et on l'a dit tout à l'heure, le
problème c'est que
la guerre, la négociation de la fin de
la guerre, ça se négocia entre les
Russes, les Américains et les Ukrainiens
et nous on n pas dedans. Bon deuxième
volet quand on quand on a eu la guerre
dans un pays, c'est le reconstruire. Bon
parce que tout le monde intérêt
évidemment dit c'est bon pour gagner un
peu d'argent hein. Bon retrouver un peu
les sous qu'on a perdu comme dirait
l'autre. Bon, mais là, il s'est passé
quand même un truc, c'est que Zelenski
il y a de il y a un an et demi, enfin
bref, il y a un peu plus d'un an, a
signé un accord de reconstruction de
l'Ukraine avec Black Rock, avec les
Américains de Black Rock. Donc, si tu
veux, là, on est mal parti.
avant la guerre, les Américains et les
trois sociétés américaines puis une
société française le groupe avril ont
acheté les terres à blé ukrainiennes.
D'ailleurs, au parlement ukrainien, les
les parlementaires ont protesté contre
Zelenski en disant "Vous bradez nos
meilleurs terres en les vendant aux
Américains, hein." Et entre parenthèses,
c'est pour ça qu'au début de la guerre,
quand tout le monde protestait pour
l'envoi des bateaux de blé qui pouvaient
pas passer, c'était pas du blé
ukrainien, c'était du blé américain.
Faut le savoir quand même. Bon, en
grande partie, pas tout mais en grande
partie le donc il y avait il y a un
troisème volet qui a été négocié par
Trump avec Zelenski. Là, c'est fait dans
le dernier voyage de Zelenski aux
États-Unis. Ça a été lui a dit "Bon,
vous nous devez beaucoup d'argent.
parce qu'on vous a beaucoup aidé pour
cette guerre, il faut rembourser.
Donc comment vous allez rembourser ?
Vous nous donnez toutes les terrares,
l'exploitation des terrares, des mines
intéressantes qu'il y a chez vous.
Ça ressemble un peu à de la mafia ça,
non ?
Ouais. Bah oui, mais résultat de
l'opération. Tu veux la reconstruction,
on n pas la reconstruction des villes et
tout parce que c'est Black Rock. On n
pas les terrablé. Bon, c'est un et on n
pas et on on n pas on n pas les mines,
on a plus rien.
Alors ouais et ça me moi ça me rappelle
parce que je suis je suis un vieux de la
vieille, ça me rappelle l'histoire de
l'Irak quand on avait fait la guerre en
Irak avec
la première ou la deuxème
la première. On a quand on a fait la
guerre en Irak avec les Américains. Bon
et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? Bon on a été
on a envoyé là-bas à la division
d'Aguay. On avait envoyé la division
d'Aguay. On s'était battu là-bas. Très
bien. Et on a dit à la fin, on a dit bon
pour la reconstruction, on voudrait
quand même participer. On a dit parfait.
Ils nous ont dit les Américains ont dit
parfait hein. Alors vous allez déminer
les plages de City.
Et voilà ce qu'on a fait dans la
reconstruction he de l'Irak. On a on a
déminé les plages de City, tu vois. Bon
alors tu parles pas des balcans où là
pratiquement on a rien eu.
C'est sur la deuxième, j'avais un copain
euh que tu connais d'ailleurs.
Ouais. qui revenait euh euh et qui me
disait "Non mais c'est fou, les
Américains ils ont des pouvoirs
régaliens."
Mais oui, mais oui, si tu veux. C'est
pour ça. Alors, alors dans cette dans
cette affaire donc c'est vrai que on se
retrouve
et c'est ça, on a on a nos on est
complètement on est mal donc on est on
n'est pas dans la paix la négociation
des conditions de paix. On n'est pas
on n'intervient pas beaucoup, c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire. On n'est pas on
sera pas dans la reconstruction. Alors,
qu'est-ce qui nous reste ? Il nous reste
effectivement le côté militaire, c'est
il va falloir mettre des forces
prépositionnées le long de la frontière.
Les Américains veulent se replier, ils
le disent hein, ils sont enlevés en
train d'envoyer d'enlever une brigade en
Allemagne, ils veulent se retirer
d'Europe au niveau militaire. C'est pour
ça que Trump dit que l'OTAN doit être
avec des armées européennes mais
équipées de matériel américain quand
même. Il faut faire des affaires, hein.
Et donc et qu'est-ce qu'il dit ? On va
vous équiper en matériel américain et
c'est vous qui allez vous prépositionner
là-haut. Donc ce que dans l'affaire et
oui dans l'affaire ukrainienne c'est qui
si tu regardes
c'est la peur l'argent du beurre la
créen de la créer Ah ouais c'est clair
c'est clair les Américains ils sont
gagnants sur tous les tableaux mais nous
on a alors on peut se poser des
questions parce que en définitive
pourquoi s'est-on laissé enfermer dans
cette position là alors que on était on
travaillait avec les Américains avant
assez assez bien pourquoi a-t-on voulu
jouer un jeu particulier si ve au niveau
européen Ça c'est une question qu'il
faudra se poser ensuite. Bah pas c'est
pas moi, c'est les historiens qui se la
poseront. C'est comment alors qu'on
était avec les Américains et que donc on
devrait être avec eux pour la
négociation et tout, comment on a été
amené à prendre des positions tellement
opposées aux Américains que maintenant
on est en dehors du coup ?
Je
C'est une vraie question.
Je reviens sur la menace russe.
Donc nous nous euh on suit le problème
depuis à peu près fin 2015.
Ouais. Euh, on avait senti le cou venir,
on s'est déplacé sur place, on a discuté
avec plein de personnes sur place, on a
fait venir des diplomates russes ici
pour discuter de l'anticipation,
de l'odeur de poudre qu'on était en
train de sentir, ce léger fumet par
rapport à leurs exercices pour sortir du
soif, leurs exercices pour sortir
d'internet,
se dépluguer, faire un intranet russe,
un runette à la sauce, on sentait le
souffre dans le coin. On a discuté avec
toutes ces petites personnes,
connaissait les diplomates, langue de
bois, ils ont la même langue de bois que
que les nôtres.
Et on s'est intéressé dans le côté
techyber.
Oui, bien sûr.
Et on s'est intéressé sur les menaces
troll.
Oui.
À Saint-Pétersbourg, la première bien
sûr, l'usine à troll de
Saint-Pétersbourg entre
2500 m² sont passés à 4000 m², plus de
4000 m², ils sont passés à 15000 m². On
a même été titillé le bras droit du
ministère de l'intérieur russe pendant
le confinement où il y avait un
colloque.
On leur a dit "C'est quoi ces histoires
de fermatrol ?" Ils ont ils nous ont
prétexté qu'il nous entendaient pas.
Bon, l'argument classique, j'entends pas
la question. On leur a répondu
"Écoute-moi bien,
le micro que j'ai, c'est tel micro, la
connexion c'est tel micro. Si un
problème c'est c'est de ton côté, comme
les Russes détestent perdent la face,
ils ont dit "Ah, on vous entend bien."
Et on lui a reposé la question sur les
fermatrol, comment ça se passe ? comment
le ministère de l'intérieur réagit russe
euh et parce qu'on leur a dit c'est en
train de rotonn de pourrir la relation
franco-russe parce que on voit nos
journalistes lever des lièvres un peu
partout, on voit des guerres raconter
n'importe quoi sur internet et ainsi de
suite.
Et donc pour terminer ce trucl,
on voit les numéros d'urgence européens,
français, portugais se faire emmerder.
On voit notre ministre du cyber raller,
on voit le ministère de l'intérieur
français raller, on voit tous ces petits
copain allemands dire "On est attaqué
tous les jours" et désigner les Russes
quand tu as des numéros d'urgence qui
sont attaqués, neutralisés en cas de
conflit quand il y a le bordel, si les
gens peuvent pas appeler le pompier, ils
deviennent complètement dingo.
Et on voit tout un tas de manœuvres dans
l'éventualité d'un conflit réel. Alors,
il y a peut-être là-dedans des groupes
ukrainiens, russes, euh nord-coréens qui
qui prennent du blé et que c'est pas du
tout les Russes. Mais il y a quand même
un un chemin, un patterne,
un schéma
qui sent le souffre.
Ils ont quand même des des biscuits nos
États-majors pour dire "Les Russes c'est
des méchants" ou il racontent n'importe
quoi ?
Ah non, il raconte pas n'importe quoi.
Tu tu viens de le dire, les usines à trô
elles existent. On peut pas nier
alors la réponse du ministère de de
russe
oui
c'est des entreprises privées, on peut
rien faire.
Oui mais attendant tu sais ça me
rappelle moi ça me rappelle quand il y
avait à une époque moi j'avais parlé de
l'Afrique hein euh et je disais en
Afrique il y a il y a les mercenaires
russes de Wagner et les Russes avaient
dit mais enfin c'est absolument faux.
Nous n'avons jamais eu de mercenaire
chez nous. Et puis et puis manque de
peau hein, il y a eu Wagner, on l'a vu à
Bmou, à la bataille de Barmou et après
on les a vu tentant de renverser le
mystère de la défense hein dans
l'attaque dans une attaque en Russie.
Donc on a vu que
ils sont pas allés bien loin. Il y avait
des tranchées sur les aut.
Ouais. Donc il y avait des manip donc
c'est sûr que les Russes ils te disent
pas ce qu'ils font, ils le disent pas
hein. Bon ou alors quand c'est de la
propagande ou si
pourquoi nous on dit ce qu'on fait ? Ah
mais moi je pense qu'ils veulent je
pense qu'ils veulent nous déstabiliser
pour plusieurs raisons, si tu veux.
Euh d'abord quand tu regardes les pays
européens
euh tu en as un certain nombre qui ont
pris des positions très avancées par
rapport à d'autres hein. Nous les
Français, on a pris des positions très
avancées par rapport aux Russes, hein.
On est on est très agressif hein.
Regarde tout ce qu'on a pu dire et tout.
Les Allemands, c'est pas mieux, hein.
Les Allemands aussi. Bon, les Anglais
n'en parlons pas, ils bon les trois.
Mais tu as plein d'autres pays en Europe
qui sont pas du tout comme ça. Alors je
parle pas de la Hongrie qui est qui est
bon avec Orbane mais même la la Pologne,
la Hongrie, la Roumanie, l'Italie
l'Italie de ce côté-là est beaucoup
moins agressive que nous hein. On vient
de le voir hier encore quand il y a eu
l'affaire de Vever, enfin l'affaire des
actifs russes que la Commission
européenne veut saisir, ce qui est un
une violation du droit international
absolu, hein.
le belge, le premier ministre belge qui
lui ben il a peur parce que la plus
grande partie de ses actifs sont en
Belgique et qui veut pas se faire
attaquer ensuite pour avoir
attaquer devant les tribunaux.
Devant les tribunaux exactement hein,
avec des demandes de remboursement et
non seulement remboursement mais même
d'indemnité parce que c'est illégal. Bon
le donc de vert il a dit moi je veux
pas. Bon, il y a l'Italie hein a dit
mais je suis d'accord avec moi je peux
te dire en écoutant ça hier j'ai dit
Mélonie est très maline parce que
Poutine qui regarde ça il dit quels sont
les pays qui sont prêts à saisir mon
fric et quels sont les pays qui sont
prêts à m'aider et quand il voit que
Mélanie elle agresse pas il dit Mélanie
on fera des affaires avec elle plus tard
alors que nous ben évidemment nous on
dit vous allez voir ben évidemment ça se
passe mal et et alors Alors comment dans
nos pays ? Ben ça c'est la guerre cyber
si tu veux. La guerre cyber c'est une
réalité mais pas c'est une réalité de
temps de paix comme en temps de guerre
hein.
Les Américains savent de quoi ils
parlent.
Bah les Américains, c'est ils l'ont
commencé hein. Les Américains ont
commencé. Après, on a vu les Chinois, on
a vu les Russes, on a vu les Coréens du
Nord qui sont qui sont pas mauvais du
tout, hein. Un certain nombre de pays
qui ont qui pratique à travers des
groupes et autres, mais plus ou moins
contrôlés par l'État qui pratiquent hein
les attaques cyberes. Alors, l'attaque
cyber, il y en a plusieurs types mais il
y en a une qu'il faut bien voir, c'est
pour le cas où j'aurais à l'utiliser en
temps de guerre, il faut que je fasse
des tests.
test par exemple, est-ce que je suis
capable avec mon système de bloquer
le réseau électrique ?
Le réseau électrique. Voilà. Alors, je
fais un test sur une ville et puis la
ville pendant 12h elle a pas
d'électricité.
Bloquer les hôpitaux.
Oui. Ou bloquer les hôpitaux, on l'a vu.
Bloquer les numéros d'urgence.
Mais tout. Oui, exactement. On peut
faire des quantités de choses si tu
veux.
Bloquer par exemple les navires de
croisière avec plein de vieux à
l'intérieur en changeant le logiciel de
routage et aller le faire écraser sur
des rochers.
Oui. Oui. Mais tout est possible si tu
veux. Il y a regarde regarde le comment
les regarde si tu discutes avec les gens
d'Airbus, ils diront que ils consacrent
de gros moyens hein à à des à faire à
monter des systèmes qui empêchent que
par la voie cyber on puisse prendre le
contrôle de leurs avions. Parce
qu'imagine un peu un hackur qui prend le
contrôle d'un avion, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Pirate un pirate,
hein ? Oui,
un pirate, pas un rur, un pirate.
Oui, enf oui, enfin, oui, hein. Donc,
c'est pour ça que si tu veux, on est
dans un on est dans une
évolution où tout le monde attaque tout
le monde pour faire des tests et puis
aussi de temps en temps aussi parce que
ça dit bah tiens, on va leur mettre un
coup sur la tête, hein. Tu as fait une
déclaration qui a pas plu. Bon, bah dit
bah tiens, on va se venger. Avant, on
allait te menacer, on allait faire même
des des on a vu que les sanctions par
exemple, ça marche pas terrible hein.
Les sanctions économiques, ça marche pas
terrible. J'ai l'impression que ça a
jamais marché sauf sur l'Afrique du Sud.
Mais oui, mais bien sûr ça marche pas.
C'est
qu'on a discuté avec les Iraniens. Les
Iranien quand même.
Mais attends, mais ça marche pas pour
une raison très simple, c'est que quels
sont les pays font les sanctions ? Les
pays les pays européens et les
États-Unis. Est-ce que les pays
européens et les États-Unis représentent
le monde entier ? Bah réponse, non. Il
représentent pas 50 %, il représente pas
40 % du total.
Donc avec quand tu ne reprendes pas la
majorité, bah tu peux pas réussir ton
coût. Si si tu veux si tu veux faire
plier quelque chose, il faut que tu sois
largement majoritaire.
Si tu encercles un pays à 80 % va être
difficile pour eux de pouvoir s'en
sortir. Si tu l'encercles avec 30 %
simplement, bah ils vont passer sur les
70 % restants. Revenons revenons sur la
menace russe.
Oui.
Euh je me mets à la place d'Emmanuel
Macron, même si c'est difficile, ou de
son chef d'étatmajor, même si c'est
encore plus difficile.
Ah oui, c'est sûr.
Euh
on a une économie de guerre en face de
nous. Oui,
on a une population
qui a une résilience, une robustesse,
une mentalité.
Plus tu lui tapes sur la gueule, plus il
deviennent dur.
Oui, mais ils sont très nationalistes,
hein.
Patriote.
Oui, patriote si tu veux. Oui, pour
employer mot, c'est plus tu as plus tu
as raison. Exactement. C'est vrai, c'est
patriote. On peut dire patriote.
Ils ont un culte des morts et un culte
sacrificiel à la guerre et à la bravoure
que nous on a oublié.
Oui. Ouais. Euh tous les ans, ils font
euh la parade avec les vieux euh de la
famille qui a qu'est-ce qui se passe les
gars ? Je t'ai dit quand tu me fais des
tu discute avec l'ingénération, c'est
remets ton micro ou
bien mon micro.
Non, je sais pas, il y a le va remettre
le micro. On a on a un nouveau. Non,
mais tu peux y aller de bout hein,
t'inquiète.
Bon de pile, non ? Alors, je vais faire
la causette pendant que il est en train
de de d'éviter de se faire.
Donc, on a une population qui a euh
Ouais,
je je sais alors je fais pour la blague.
Il te teste ton micro mais il a même pas
mis son casque. Donc il va attendre et
donc vas-y parle un peu. On est bon.
Ouais. 5 sur 5 fort éclair. On est bon.
Désolé. Non mais c'est qu'il est très
tatillant.
C'est pour ça qu'il travaille avec nous.
Donc revenons revenons à cette petite
déconcentration.
On a une économie de guerre où ils sont
à 5 % voire 7,5 % déclarés de leur
économie en terme de PIB.
Ils ont une mentalité qui est différente
de la nôtre. Ils ont vécu l'effondrement
de l'action soviétique et les gens qui
sont actuellement au pouvoir et dans les
cabinets autour des cabinets, ce sont
les gamins de l'époque qui ont vu des
pénuries dans les les supermarchés et
j'en passe le phénomène de mafia, de
corruption et d'ex clair, ils ont ils
ont tout connu
et donc là ils sont au pouvoir, ils ont
prévenu quand on a commencé à enquêter
sur le conflit qui venait, on les voyait
quand on se baladait à l'ONU ou à parce
que on se balade de temps en temps
et on les voyait qui venait chouiner
dans tous les les organismes
internationaux. Le Donbas c'est
compliqué. C'était à la même époque où
ils avaient leur démographie qui était
en chute libre et qui lançait les
programmes de
soutien auprès des familles. Des
familles. Oui. Point soutien des
familles. Oui.
Donc nous nous on a dit ils sont en
train de reconstituer leur stock
d'homme. Ils mettent des subventions sur
les familles parce que ça leur permet
d'avoir un stock d'or d'homme plus tard.
Ils relancent l'économie, ils font la
rénovation des hôpitaux en Brudo de
Moscou, ils se préparent, ils font les
exercices Swift, ils font les exercices,
tout ça. Donc il y a un truc qui qui se
prépare. Là, on est en guerre, ils
veulent pas le dire en Europe, mais on
est en guerre contre eux. Et maintenant,
les Russes la moutarde leur est monté au
nez. Ils considèrent les pays européens
non plus comme des partenaires, non pas
comme des amis, mais comme des
puissances hostiles.
Oui.
Comment ça va s'arrêter cette histoire ?
Parce que tu connais une économie de
guerre. L'économie de guerre réclame
toujours du sang.
Oui,
les Européens doivent se dire la même
chose que nous. Ils doivent se dire "Ils
sont lancés sur leur trajectoire, ils
sont fâchés contre nous, on a des
diplomates et des des tuyaux de poil, un
peu n'importe quoi." Euh ils nous
considèrent comme des gens qui n'ont pas
de parole. Euh, ils vont peut-être se
fâcher derrière. Ça va prendre quelle
forme ? La forme de guerre économique,
la forme d'invasion, la forme de
déstabilisation ? Ils vont faire
simplement la chose suivante, c'est au
lieu que nous nous déployons le rideau
de fer, eux vont déployer le rideau de
fer et ils vont attendre que l'Europe
soit croupisse économiquement parce
qu'ils savent pertinemment que les
fondamentaux de l'économie européenne
sont morts.
Où est-ce qu'ils vont attendre le
changement par des déstabilisations, les
changements des politiques européennes ?
Alors tu as raison, c'est c'est une
vraie question hein. Euh c'est
difficile.
Tu as cru que tu te déplaçais pourquoi ?
Non non non non mais c'est une vraie
question qui est qui si je veux parce
que
comme tu l'as très justement dit on est
comme c'est difficile de passer c'est
pas facile de passer l'écoming guerre à
l'économie de paix donc il faut il faut
il il y a un atterrissage si tu veux qui
se fait et qui prend un certain temps.
Le ce qu'on ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
en Europe comme je l' dit tout à
l'heure, tu as un certain nombre de pays
qui ne sont pas antirusses si tu veux,
qui sont pas mouillés dans cette
affaire,
qui sont pas entis ou qui ont peur.
Euh
je ça ça oui, ça c'est difficile. C'est
difficile. Je je crois qu'il y a des
pays qui actuellement sont la propagande
si tu veux. Alors la France,
l'Angleterre, l'Allemagne, il y a eu des
campagnes, il y a eu des campagnes
tellement fortes pour dire il faut pas
aimer les Russes, c'est des affreux et
tout ça que il y a il y a aujourd'hui il
y a un blocage face à la situation, un
blocage face aux Russes qui est
réellement très fort. Mais il y a
beaucoup d'autres pays où c'est pas du
tout comme ça. Donc je pense que la
Russie s'il y a la paix hein, s'il y a
la paix avec l'Europe, la Russie va
s'appuyer sur les pays qui seront resté
raisonnable, je dirais relativement
raisonnable.
Raisonnable ou soumis ?
Bah c'est raisonnable si tu veux. Je
pense moi, je pense à la Pologne, je
pense à la je pense à la Hongrie, je
pense à la Tchéquie, je pense à la
Roumanie, je pense à la Bulgarie. Entre
parenthèses, c'est tous les pays,
pratiquement tous les pays de la zone,
hein, limitrophe. Je pense aussi à
l'Italie. Euh c'est des pays qui en
définitive je pense qu'ils vont tirer
par ils vont tirer les marrons du feu
dans cette affaire. Ils vont développer
des relations avec la avec la Russie.
Alors et dans le même temps, la Russie
ne fera aucun cadeau aux trois pays qui
ont été totalement opposés à elle en
Europe, à savoir l'Angleterre,
l'Allemagne et la France. Et comment ça
peut se contenu de tout ce qu'on vient
de dire et des attaques cyberes de tout
ce qui se passe ? parce qu'il y a des
choses qui continueront, faut pas se
leurer hein. La guerre cyber, elle
s'arrête pas avec la guerre tout court
hein. Bon le on aura probablement une
des tentatives de déstabilisation
de l'Union européenne parce qu'elle a
été contre eux hein de l'Union
européenne. C'està dire que ils
essaieront probablement ils essaieront
de contribuer aux oppositions des pays
dans le cadre de l'Europe. Alors est-ce
que ça amènera à une révision de
l'Europe, une un redéploiement de
l'Europe, une réflexion sur l'Europe ?
euh où ça y contribuera parce que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut que l'Europe évolue. Alors si tu
veux, il y a tout ça, ça va se mélanger.
C'est difficile de dire comment ça
comment ça va se terminer mais de toute
manière je pense qu'on est parti pour
une évolution de l'Europe à la après la
paix en Ukraine, ça c'est sûr. Bon,
comme tu le sais, depuis des années, on
adore le terrain.
Ouais.
Le terrain, c'est ce qui permet de faire
mentir les experts de plasto télé.
Absolument. Et quand je te parle de
terrain, je te parle pas de terrain de
tour opérator derrière les lignes
ennemies euh euh ou euh en face des
lignes ennemies.
Tu me parles pas d'un philosophe qui se
fait photographier ? Euh
je vois pas de qui tu parles du tout.
Je te parle pas de de de techniciens.
Euh
d'accord. Non non, on est d'accord. On
tous les tous ces experts qui soi-disant
par de de
on parle des vrais des gens qui sont
des nouveaux touristes.
C'est ça. Des nouveaux touristes. Voilà.
Et on a rencontré Sergier Lavrof. Oui,
en 2019, fin 2019 en marge du forum pour
la paix à Paris parce que tu comme tu le
sais, on n' pas beaucoup de pognons
d'ailleurs, financz-nous avec Tipi.
Mais c'est intéressant. C'est
euh on a attrapé Lavrov euh euh sur
Paris, on lui a posé la question "Les
yeux dans les yeux, on lui a dit "Nous,
on sait que la guerre vient,
h
on sait que vous vous préparez.
Quelle tournure ça prend H euh, ils nous
ont fait le baiser de la mort derrière,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont publié notre
vraie tête avec notre vrai nom, ainsi de
suite. Ils ont fait les effarouchés
qu'ils avaient pas fait exprès, mais ils
nous ont fait baiser de la mort.
Et ça, on est toujours vivant donc ils
ont raté leur baiser de la mort mais on
a pu lever les anglais et le groupe
qu'ils avaient implémenté un peu partout
en Europe et surtout en France, on a pu
l'élever grâce à ça. Donc ça nous a
permis en fait de de bien scanner la
de mieux comprendre un peu tout ça. Oui.
Oui. Et surtout qui pousse vers quoi ?
Ouais.
La réaction quand on a discuté avec
Laavrof, le gros avantage de fumer des
clopes et quand vous êtes le seul autour
de la table à fumer des clopes, c'est
qu'il y a ce cette petite comment
t'expliquer ? Bon, c'est la fin de
l'année, on est au pinard donc on va
prendre un peu plus de temps, on va
donner un peu de notre personne auprès
de notre communauté. Quand vous êtes
autour de la table et que il y a que des
culs serrés et que vous faites chier
comme un ramort et que bah vous pensez
qu'une seule chose c'est fumer une clope
et que vous tapez votre clop sur la
table, la vrovis c'est un [__] de
fumeur. Il fume des clopes toutes les 5
minutes.
Donc on s'allume une clope, ça crée un
un un demilien sanitaire par rapport à
tout ce talibanisme sanitaire ambiant.
Ne fumez pas, c'est très mauvais.
Et ensuite, on discute les yeux dans les
yeux d'homme à homme.
On les a senti, du moins nous, on l'a
senti
euh comment tu dis ça ? Euh
il avait peur.
Oui, il c'estàd que quand on lui a dit
on sait que la guerre arrivera et ça il
y a très de très fortes chances que ça
se finisse au nucléaire.
Ouais.
Bon, à tous les coups nous a pris pour
un mec de la DGSE.
Ah non mais tu attends tu avais tu as
tout à fait raison. Lavrof
toute toute personne censée il est censé
Laavrof il est pas il défend son pays il
défend sa politique la police son pays
mais il est un type sensé. Bon quand tu
vois une guerre qui démarre qui
s'annonce exactement tu te demandes
toujours si c'est comment cette guerre
va évoluer. Est-ce que ça restera une
guerre locale avec des moyens locaux ou
est-ce qu'on va basculer sur le
nucléaire ? Si on bascule sur le
nucléaire c'est l'horreur absolue si tu
veux. C'est c'est une forme de 3e guerre
mondiale. Il y a des alors là c'est des
millions de morts hein parce que chaque
bombe qui tombe sur une ville ben c'est
des millions de morts. On n'est pas du
tout dans une quelque chose de de
joyeux. C'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire, hein. Bon, alors
dans aujourd'hui, si tu veux, moi je
crois qu'on est
les Russes savent maintenant parce
qu'ils ont vu avec les Américains puis
on est on n'est pas parti dans une
guerre nucléaire
hein. Et ils veulent régler le problème.
Ils ont compris avec Trump qu'ils
peuvent régler le problème
tel qu'il le souhaitait parce que on
retrouve les objectifs qu'ils avaient au
début de la guerre quand même. Donc pour
les pour les Russes, il ils ont atteint
leurs objectifs de guerre
encore.
Pas presque presque. Attends parce que
ils ont d'un côté ils ont ils ont encore
un trou dans le Donbas à côté avant
Karmators la zone autour de Kramators
mais de l'autre côté à Zaporij ils ont
avancé donc il y a aussi des échanges
possibles. il y a beaucoup de choses qui
Mais de toute manière si tu veux qu'on
qu'on s'arrête sur la ligne de front,
qu'on s'arrête sur la ligne de la
frontière du Donbas,
de toute manière le problème, il y a une
une certitude, c'est que les alliés et
les Ukrainiens en tout cas ne peuvent
plus reprendre un pouce de terrain. Ça
c'est fini, c'est on le sait, c'est cuit
hein, c'est fini. Donc à partir de ce
moment-là, il faut effectivement arrêter
la guerre et il tout le monde le sait
qu'il faut arrêter la guerre et ceux qui
ça va pas s'arrêter d'un coup même si
les Ukrain signent ça
on va dire ils vont négocier
le russe le russe est relativement
encunier. Oui oui mais oui mais ça oui
mais ça alors c'est ce qu'on a dit tout
à l'heure. Moi je crois que la guerre
s'arrêtera en tant que guerre physique
si tu veux que est actuel il y aura un
traité de paix il y aura plein de choses
mais c'est sûr que par les attaques
cyber elles continueront vers des pays
qui ont été considérés comme inamicaux.
Ça, je me fais pas d'illusion. Euh et
donc il faudra je pense que
malheureusement hein ou heureuse enfin
j'en sais rien euh malheureusement mais
je pense quand même que la France risque
d'avoir des problèmes d'où la nécessité
de se protéger hein. Ça c'est clair.
Le au tout départ de la je vais je vais
donner une confidence. Au tout départ de
la guerre comme on avait senti le truc
on a appelé quelques copains qui
bossaient dans le renseignement
pour aller boire des bières et pour
faire de la prospective et faire
phosphorer nos cerveaux pour pouvoir
être affuté.
Euh, on a vu la technologie russe
rentrer en action, leur missile
noisette,
machin, les Mac 9, les Mac 10, les Mac
12,
leur missile, du moins leur torpill
poséidon. De notre côté, ça ça a créé de
notre côté européen, ça a créé des
craintes et réarmement réarmement
réarmement. Est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression de voir une stratégie de
guerre froide d'épuisement économique
mais inversé ce coup-ci ? C'est-à-dire
que les Russes sont l'énergie,
les Européens sont dans une dans une
mouise noire énergétiquement parlant et
est-ce que les Russes sont pas en train
de nous faire la stratégie qu'ils
connaissent et qu'ils ont subi,
c'est-à-dire une course alarmement qui
fera effondrer nos économies ?
Alors
encore une bonne question he
Oui. Une bonne question. Alors, une
chose est certaine si tu veux, c'est que
la guerre en Ukraine a été un peu comme
on avait connu la guerre en la guerre en
Espagne en dans les années 36 38 39.
C'est-à-dire que on a testé les
occidentaux comme les Russes ont testé
quantité de matériel là-bas. C'est
normal, on en profite, on profite des
guerres pour tester le matériel.
Ça c'est un premier point. Un 2e point,
c'est qu'on a vu effectivement que les
Russes avaient certains certaines armes
extrêmement performantes et qu'ils
avaient qui mettaiit en œuvre euh et qui
là qui pose des problèmes parce que euh
ben c'est les missiles hypersoniques
qu'on sait pas arrêté parce que comme
ils sont hypersoniques, on n' pas de
défense qui les arrêtent. Euh c'est tu
as parlé de la fameuse torpille qui est
ultra rapide mais de
je te parle pas je parle pas de cheval
je parle de la grosse eau nucléaire.
Oui, mais mais oui, al aussi il y avait
on a vu aussi des missiles volant enfin
des oui des des engins des drones
volants avec une charge avec une avec un
moteur nucléaire, il pouv en faire 14000
km, ce qui énorme hein, parce que ça
veut dire que ils peuvent aller, très
important, ils partent du Russie, ils
tournent par l'Afrique du Sud, ils
remontent par l'Amérique du Sud et ils
attaquent les États-Unis, hein. C'est
c'est pas Donc là, pour les repérer,
c'est cuit parce que nous en défense,
tous les radars, ils sont orientés au
nord, hein. Ils sont pas orientés
enfin ils sont pas orientés vers le sud.
Donc donc il y a il y a il y a beaucoup
de choses qu'on a découvertes et qui
sont qui leur permettent effectivement
de enfin ça nous permet de dire oui les
Russes ont maintenant alors ils n'ont
pas tout he il y a une partie de l'armée
qui est obsolète hein mais il une partie
qui est très performante.
OK.
Du côté des Européens, on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure, nous on a une armée qui
est dépassée par qui n'est pas structuré
avec des moyens les moyens qu'il
faudrait pour faire face à ce type de
guerre. On le sait, il faut qu'on
investisse. Bon, les Américains, ils
veulent faire la paix. Ils ont pas envie
de faire un bras de fer avec les Russes.
Eux ce qu'ils veulent, c'est que les
Russes soient suffisamment
économiquement liés avec eux pour ne
plus avoir à s'en occuper. Donc
là-dedans, Poutine et son équipe, ils
ont tout intérêt à développer l'économie
si tu veux en jouant bien sûr, ils
continueront à jouer sur la Chine, ils
continueront à jouer également sur les
mais ils continueront aussi à jouer avec
les États-Unis parce que à partir des
accords de paix, ils continueront. Donc,
on va avoir des deux côtés sur la Russie
va jouer de tous les côtés. Alors,
est-ce qu'elle peut s'intéresser à
l'Europe ? Alors, je crois que le probl
un des problèmes que nous avons, c'est
que nous nous avons fait des sanctions.
On a coupé les ponts avec la Russie
complètement. Bon, est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
la Russie a besoin de nous ?
Tu vois sur le plan, regarde sur le plan
par exemple de la les plans
alimentaires,
on a décidé de plus envoyer en Russie
les produits français et autres qu'on
envoyait. Bon, qui les a qui nous a
remplacé ? les Turcs
ou les Suisses,
hein. Oui. Pourquoi tu veux qu'il
changent ? Pourquoi tu veux que
maintenant ils reviennent aux Français ?
Puisque ça marche avec les Turcs, tu
vois ? Et donc c'est ça le problème si
tu veux. On a ils ont pris des habitudes
de travailler avec d'autres et donc le
besoin européen est beaucoup plus réduit
qu'avant.
Ça c'est clair. Et nous on va alors bien
sûr, qu'est-ce qui va se passer dès la
paix ? Tu vas avoir une quantité de pays
européens qui vont dire il y a quand
même un gros marché en Russie. on va y
aller ou on va y retourner, hein. Mais
surtout on va y aller. Et là et ben ça
va être probablement pour eux très
difficile parce que les Russes vont leur
dire "Attendez, pendant la guerre on
vous a pas vu. Donc pourquoi voulez-vous
qu'on vous tende la main ? Maintenant
préfère continuer à travailler avec les
pays du proche Orient, avec les pays
d'Asie et ainsi de suite. C'est c'est ça
si tu veux. Donc il y a un changement,
il y a un changement au niveau de la des
échanges et que nous avons provoqué mais
qui va qui va continuer à après la paix.
Quelle lecture stratégique, quelle
prospective tu as sur l'Europe,
sur les économies européennes, sur les
flux migratoire, sur les capacités des
gouvernements à encaisser X ou Y
problème, la l'alignement des problèmes.
Oui.
La dette, le logement, l'inflation,
l'inflation sur les matières premières
alimentaires, l'inflation sur les
matières premières de construction, le
bois, le béton et j'en passe des
meilleurs. Ascier
ta prospective sur l'Europe, on l'a dans
l'os 20 prochaines années. Nos
dirigeants sont en train de faire des
budgets de réarmement pour perrorer que
tout va bien parce que ça va nous mettre
un petit coup d'adrénaline sur notre
économie à très court terme. Quelle
lecture tu as ? Est-ce que c'est positif
? Est-ce que je me trompe ? Est-ce que
ils vont nous sortir quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ? On l'a tellement dans
l'ositer
et faire du bruit avec leur bouche pour
justifier leur salaire de crétin.
Écoute, le
si tu regardes la réalité,
l'Europe aujourd'hui est une Europe qui
tourne en croissance entre 0 et 1.
Pour combien de dettes ? Pour
attends, avec une dette abissale et avec
la France qui est le record absolu pour
la dette.
Donc on peut pas dire avec moins d'un %
de croissance comment tu rembourses ta
dette. Tu peux pas.
Tu peux pas ou pratiquement pas si tu
veux. Il faut de la croissance pour
rembourser de la dette ou de
l'inflation, hein. Or, le système euh de
l'euro empêche d'avoir de l'inflation,
hein. Et oui, c'est le système qu'on a
choisi, hein, le système de l'euros. un
système qui était le système allemand
par opposition au système qu'avaient les
pays du sud de l'Europe, l'Espagne, la
France, l'Italie ou la Grèce, on avait
un système inflation avait de
l'inflation et on faisait inflation
d'évaluation et on faisait comme ça hein
alors que les Allemands c'étaient comme
ça. Bon le résultat aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a choisi le système allemand mais
que visiblement on sait pas le gérer
hein puisque nous on a toujours des
dettes qui ne font qu'augmenter. Donc on
a on a un problème.
Alors donc on est en très mauvaise
situation. Clair. L'Union européenne
n'est pas en bonne situation non plus
parce qu'elle a perdu aujourd'hui. Elle
a des elle est en crise interne, on le
voit, il y a des votes d'opposition, ils
arrivent plus. Mais c'est normal, à 28,
tu peux pas gérer 28 personnes aussi
différentes que des gens du nord de
l'Europe, du sud de l'Europe et de la
moyenne Europe.
On peut qu'on veuille ou qu'on veuille
pas, c'est pas la même chose hein. C'est
pas les mêmes problèmes, c'est pas la
même culture, c'est pas la même
habitude, c'est pas les mêmes économies,
tout est différent. Alors tu bon tu les
mets ensemble hein quand tu te mélanges
des torchons et des serviettes et ben ça
donne pas de bons résultats hein. Ça
donne pas des draps en soi ça c'est
clair. Ou alors c'est qu'il y a il y a
un tour de passe pas tour de magie mais
enfin sinon il y a pas hein. Donc on est
on est on est dans une très mauvaise
situation en Europe. On est dans une
mauvaise situation en France faut le
dire. Mais il y a pas qu'en France hein.
L'Allemagne est pas si brillante que ça.
L'Allemagne 94 % je parle de tête. Je
demande à me faire fa checker. Tiens,
réveille-toi toi.
Le 94 % des des industries lourdes
allemandes ont épuisé toutes leurs
solutions et pensent à s'expatrier.
Mais oui,
à cause de l'énergie. Mais bien entendu,
parce que le coût de l'énergie c'est tu
tu as raison d'en parler parce que c'est
un des problèmes vraiment un problème
fondamental en Europe. Bon, les
Allemands avaient tout joué sur le gaz,
le gaz russe hein, ils avaient joué sur
le gaz russe. D'autant plus que comme
c'était eux qui recevaient le gaz de
Russie et que ce gaz ne passait plus par
les pays type Ukraine et autres où il
paye des royalty. Quand tu traverses un
pays, tu dois payer des royalty.
Ouais. avec la Baltique qui passait par
le par la mer Baltique. Donc il y avait
pas de donc déjà les Russes et les
Allemands se partageaient le bénéfice
déjà premier point. Ensuite, il disait
comme le le gaz russe était moins cher
que les autres, il disait "On va le
vendre à toute l'Europe." Évidemment, ça
nous intéressait hein, mais bien sûr
avec un petit pourcentage pour
l'Allemagne. Donc l'Allemagne était la
grande gagnante. Les Russes parce qu'ils
fournissaient le gaz, mais l'Allemagne
était la grande gagnante. Et parce
qu'elle savait ça, elle a elle a poussé
toute l'Europe à acheter du gaz. Et en
France, elle a fait des campagnes
d'influence pour casser l'industrie
nucléaire. On sait maintenant, il y a eu
des études là-dessus. C'est prouvé,
archi prouvé. On sait comment ils ont
fait en payant
Russe. Les Russes ont un peu aidé les
Allemands et les Allemands nous nous
Exactement hein. Et et on a bon, on sait
he il y a eu en France les ONG
françaises qui été financées par les
Allemands. Elles le savaient même pas
certaines d'entre elles hein. Et pour
détruire le nucléaire français. Pourquoi
? Parce qu'il fallait que les Français
qui avec le nucléaire avait un prix
inférieur aux Allemands basculent sur le
gaz allemand. C'était bon, ça c'était
bien joué. Bon, qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé qui a tout foutu en l'air pour
tout le monde ? C'est quand on a fait
sauter le Nordstream 2, hein, qu'est-ce
qui s'est
hein ?
C'est qui on
Attention, je veux les sources, hein.
Ouais, ouais. Non, non, moi je pense
alors si tu veux
selon certaines selon certains plus pas
mal d'informations qu'on peut avoir, il
y a quand même des doutes
saut de présemption.
Alors oui, mais je Non mais si je crois
alors je vais citer ma source. Si je
crois Simon Herch, le journaliste
américain, c'est clairement les
Américains qui ont fait le coup.
Pour ma part, je pense que c'est les
Américains aidés par les plongeurs
Norvégiens parce que les plongeurs
norvégiens sont les meilleurs plongeurs
en Europe en profondeur.
C'est pas vrai. Les meilleurs plongeurs
en profondeur, c'est les français.
Ah non, mais d'accord avec la Oui, mais
là c'est encore autre chose. Mais ça
c'est la plongée en grande profondeur si
tu veux. Les français sont les rois de
la plongée professionnelle en grande
profondeur. Mais les nageurs de combat
et les professionnels si tu veux
norvégiens sont très bons aussi. Ils
sont entraînés sur les plateformes
pétrolières en mer du Nord. Ils sont
sont bons et tout il semble bien. En
tout cas tout indique, il faut toujours
chercher à qui le crime profite hein. Et
il faut pas oublier que quand le
Nordstream a sauté, le ministre des
affaires étrangères polonais a envoyé un
message en disant "Bravo les
Américains".
Alors quand même. Alors ça c'est bon.
Alors, c'est peut-être une erreur mais
enfin bon, c'est comme ça. Après, il
s'est repris, il a dit "Non, mais on n
pas compris très bien hein. Les
Norvégiens avaient un grand sourire
parce que ça relançait évidemment le
leurs produits à eux. grand
bénéficiaire, hein. Et puis les
Américains, bah ils ont dit "Les gars,
puisqu'il y a plus de gaz là-bas, vous
allez acheter le gaz américain avec une
différence, c'est que le gaz américain,
il le vendent beaucoup plus cher, hein.
Beaucoup plus cher. Ils le vendent pour
les Européens plus cher que le prix
qu'il vendent à la pompe aux États-Unis
au particulier. Tu te rends compte les
bénéfices. Donc superbe opération pour
eux, hein. En plus, c'est du pétrole et
du gaz essentiellement de chist interdit
en Europe, en particulier en France. on
l'achète quand même hein. Et il est et
donc il est très cher et du coup ça a
bouleversé tout notre équilibre parce
que entre-temps nos politiques avait
accepté de calculer l'achat de les du
gaz sur un prix donc l'achat
l'électricité pardon sur un prix calculé
sur le gaz et maintenant c'est sur le
gaz américain. Donc si tu veux le prix
de l'électricité est énorme en Europe.
Alors les les Anglais eux ils se
débrouillent parce qu'ils sont en dehors
de l'Europe, ils font ce qu'ils veulent
mais les Allemands qui avaient calculé
tout leur industrie avec le gaz russe
avec l'augmentation des coûts qui est du
gaz allemand c'est mortel pour eux.
Donc, ils sont obligés effectivement
d'envisager l'expatriation, à envoyer
leurs usines à l'extérieur. Et les
Français, nous on a le nucléaire qui
pourrait nous nous permettre d'être
moins cher. Et dans les années
précédentes, on l'a jamais dit ça, mais
dans les années précédentes,
on payait l'électricité moins chère chez
les Français. Et ça permettait de
compenser quoi ? le fait qu'en France
les charges et les impôts sont beaucoup
plus élevés qu'en Allemagne. Donc si tu
veux par le prix de l'électricité plus
bas, on arrivait les entreprises
arrivaient à compenser partiellement
hein le fait que on avait nous des
impôts et des charges beaucoup plus
élevées que qu'en Allemagne. Là
maintenant on est tous pareil donc les
Français ça nous tue. Ah bah c'est clair
hein, mais les Allemands sont pas bien
non plus. Donc si tu veux, cette
affaire-là, elle est fondamentale parce
que ça met l'économie ça met l'économie
des pays des pays européens en l'air,
hein.
Et oui,
on parle guerre économique.
Oui, bien sûr. J'ai pas l'impression que
les Russes aient de leur côté activer le
levier guerre économique
pur et dur, c'est-à-dire nous couper le
prix du Alors, paraît-il que en 2027, on
arrêtera l'Europe
va supprimer encore les 12 % d'énergie
russe qu'on importe. J'attends de voir.
Peut-être qu'après le réarmement de
l'Allemagne avec ses 500. Attends, la
question c'est aujourd'hui on est dans
on est dans une logique de guerre donc
on annonce des sanctions contre
l'Allemagne contre la Russie la
suppression du gaz et autres mais le
jour il va y avoir la paix
est-ce que ça sera tenable ? Bien sûr
que non.
Tu penses bien que les pays du nord de
l'Europe qui sous la menace et la
pression ont accepté d'arrêter d'acheter
du gaz russe ? Mais s'il y a la paix,
qu'est-ce qu'il
la menace et la pression ? C'est pour
les valeurs.
Oui, bien entendu. Pour défendre des
valeurs fondamentales, occidentales. Ben
je je suis bien d'accord. Mais après moi
si tu veux, il y a aussi il y a à côté
des grandes idées, il y a aussi le
réalisme.
Si les pays du nord de l'Europe, les
pays les Russes viennent les voir et
leur disent "Eh, on a un pipe qui n'est
pas utilisé, qui va directement chez
vous, ben voilà, on va on va le rouvrir
et regardez à quel prix on va vous faire
payer le gaz."
Ils vont dire non.
Attends, si si tu es regarde, tu es tu
as tu as un peu d'argent hein. Tu as tu
roules en tu roules en allez en je sais
pas moi, en Twingo, hein. Bon,
grand luxe,
hein.
Grand luxe.
Grand luxe. Grand luxe. Tu ruses dans le
Twingo Grand luxe. Bon et puis il y a un
gars qui dit "Eh, si tu viens avec moi,
je te passe une grosse voiture."
Non, je préfère ma Twingo. Elle a non
moi la Ferrari jamais monsieur moi je
préfère rouler dans ma Twingo jamais
dans ma Ferrari. Bon, je veux bien,
c'est une belle histoire. Les comptes de
Noël, c'est maintenant ça marche. Mais
dans la réalité, c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe.
Si les gens ont des véritables intérêt
et tu verras s'il y a la paix, moi je
dis que le système qu'on a conçu pour
l'Europe avec le gaz va exploser en vol,
y compris avec les Allemands, hein.
D'ailleurs, je note entre parenthèses
que Trump a dit il y a il y a un mois et
demi. Alors, tu miras, il dit beaucoup
de choses Trump hein, mais il a dit un
truc quand même. Il a dit, il a répondu
à une question sur le Norstream, il a
dit "Ben, on pourrait parfaitement le
rouvrir."
Ils ont pas mis un peu de tune dans le
Nordstream là pour le récupérer ou le
racheter ? Ah mais attends, il en est
capable de passer un accord avec les
Russes en disant et on partage tu sais,
ils font des deal les Américains, c'est
des hommes de d'affairesin. C'est clair,
on le voit partout dans toutes les coins
du monde où ils sont en train de
négocier, à côté, il y a toujours un
toute une partie d'affaires qui sont
faites.
Bon, s'il y a bien un invité qui connaît
ce proverbe là, c'est bien toi. La
guerre économique,
un chômeur coûte plus cher qu'un mort.
Oui, mais exactement, un chômeur coûte
beaucoup plus cher qu'un mort. Et donc
et
moi c'est ce que me rappelais, je vais
te dire, ça me rappelle moi quand
j'étais jeune militaire parce que
j'étais j'étais militaire, j'ai eu la
chance d'être d'avoir d'être commandé
par un personnage célèbre à un moment de
ma vie qui s'appelait Bijard, hein. Et
Bijard, il avait une phrase
extraordinaire. Un jour, il nous dit euh
on lui dit "Mais pourquoi on change de
munition ? Avant on avait du 9 mm ou du
le les calibres normaux de l'armée
française ? Pourquoi on réduit ? Et et
il a dit cette phrase, il a dit "Mais
enfin
mais les munitions comme ça, elles
blessent beaucoup plus.
Un mort il est sur le terrain. Un blessé
il faut 10 personnes pour le ramener
jusqu'à l'hôpital."
Et oui, c'est alors c'est cynique si tu
veux mais c'est technique.
Ça se voit aussi dans les mines
antipersonnel d'ailleurs.
Mais bien sûr.
Donc en guerre économique euh un
chômeur, créer des chômeurs dans le la
puissance adverse, c'est beaucoup plus
efficace que s'amuser à fixer des
territoires avec des des des lignes de
front. Je me pose la question. Nous, on
a commencé à bosser sur le conflit à
venir à partir de 2015. Ouais, on a
déployé les réseaux à l'ancienne, petit
à petit, brique après brique
et bien à la française. Tu sais quand tu
vas en Russie la première fois de ta vie
que tu te fais arrêter par la douine et
que les mecs ouvrent ton sac et qui
tombe sur 12 kg de fromage et six
bouteilles de pif,
la première chose, ils éclatent de rire.
Oui, bien sûr. Ben oui,
ils je dis pour ma consommation
personnelle. Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Mais par contre pour ensuite aller boire
des coups avec les Russes et faire des
Raoul tous les 15 m, ça marche bien et
ça permet en fait ça marche
une vino véritace
qui connaissent très très bien cette
expression là
partout mais partout ça marche.
Donc on revient on enquête tout ça on
rencontre jusqu'à leur ministre des
affaires étrangères pour être vérifié
être sûr de voir l'âme qu'il a au fond
de ses yeux pour pour affiner notre
prospective. Là, je me dis nos services
de renseignement
peut-être qu'ils ont pas assez de budget
pour acheter 12 kg de pinard et 6
bouteille de rouge pour déployer des
réseaux en dehors des ces crétins de
vieux soviétologues qu'on voit la
majeure partie du temps se
comment je vais essayer de dire ça d'une
façon suffisamment propre pour éviter
que la chaîne se fasse exploser par
YouTube. Se polir le bout du gland.
Hm. à la à la peau de Chamoi sur sur
Arrêtez de rigoler
sur sur les plateaux télé
anticipé tout ça. Donc je me dis
pourquoi nos services de renseignement
n'ont pas prévenu Bruno Lemè de tenir sa
[__] de langue ? Pourquoi on n pas
prévenu Emmanuel Macron en lui disant
"Méfie-toi Coco, ils sont déjà préparés
depuis un certain nombre d'années à se
la coller contre nous avec certes des
gros missiles, des portes antisouffles,
le tout l'arsenal qui va avec, mais
surtout sur des questions de guerre
économique."
Oui. Pourquoi
est-ce que c'est mes services de
renseignement qui sont crétins jusqu'à
la moile ou est-ce que c'est la chaîne
de commandement qui est déconnecté comme
un adolescent prépuber ?
Alors,
j'allais dire les deux mon général, mais
je crois je crois
oui,
les deux. Mais je pense il y a plusieurs
choses. D'abord, les services de
renseignement n'ont découvert que
récemment en Europe, hein, récemment
l'économique.
Ah bon ?
Ça,
il faut le savoir. Ouais.
Sais que tu as essayé de militer pour
ça, mais tu as pas beaucoup été écouté.
Euh non, mais c'est vrai, c'est ils ont
des
Est-ce que tu m'autorises à couper la
parole parce que c'est bientôt Noël ?
J'ai une pensée
pour Robert Guillomo et de là où
de là où il me regarde,
je t'embrasse, je t'embrasse Robert, tu
me manques et et tu me manques.
Ouais mais mais écoute alors je partage
ton point de vue parce que c'était un
type formidable et alors là sur la
guerre économique et la guerre numérique
en particulier, c'est lui qui a été le
premier en France à évoquer tout ça et
et à expliquer comment ça pouvait
marcher. Mais il a prêché dans le désert
pendant des années. malheureux, c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire hein. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les gens n'y croyaient pas.
Alors comme tu dis, tu disais sur la
guerre économique, d'abord les services
n'y croyaient pas n'étaient pas équipés
pour ça, hein. Alors, il y a une
réaction à partir des années 2000 peu à
peu, on a dit oui, il faut quand même
s'intéresser à l'économique. Mais alors
dans les services, il y a eu un problème
à l'époque, c'est que le problème de la
guerre économique, c'est heurter avec le
problème de la guerre antiterroriste.
C'est-à-dire que les dirigeants, si tu
veux, des services sont dit "Bon,
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important ?
Est-ce qu'on fait de le renseignement
pour l'antiterrorisme parce que c'est
important de protéger les gens
mais ça va nous obliger à réduire les
moyens pas beaucoup de moyens on va pas
on pourra on va réduire la partie
économique ou le contraire ils ont
choisi l'antiterroriste c'est clair.
Je peux te couper
en France je peux te couper mais
c'est des crétins.
Ah mais je dis pas que c'est des
crétins. Je te dis, moi je constate si
tu veux
si tu te dis que tu es obligé de
rebasculer, c'est si tu es obligé de
déshabiller Paul pour réhabiller Jacques
et que tu as pas compris que l'économie
ça allait te donner plus de budget pour
pouvoir
quand tu penses écoute quand tu penses
que quand à la chute en 90 92 à la chute
du mur de Berlin le réseau échelon tu
sais qui écoutait tout le monde bon le
réseau échelon le patron à l'époque de
la enfin le patron non oui le patron de
l'ensemble des États-Unis hein le le
président Bush père le père qui était un
type très intelligent, ancien patron de
la CIA, qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ? Il a dit
vous réorientez
toutes les antennes pour que 60 % du
travail soi fait contre les entreprises
étrangères pour nous permettre de faire
gagner les entreprises américaines. Donc
là, on a basculé aux États-Unis dans les
années 90 95 92 95 on a basculé dans
l'économique à plein. Bon nous en 2000
en 2005 on était toujours pas onit
toujours pas basculé tu vois et c'est ça
qu'on paye très cher. On a mis alors on
après il y a eu une évolution qui s'est
faite peu à peu et on s'est rendu compte
que non seulement il fallait mettre des
moyens mais il fallait aussi avoir des
hommes et des femmes qui comprenaient
parce que l'économique faut quand même
avoir des gens qui ont un minimum de
notion économique si tu veux hein. Si tu
sais tirer à la kalashnikov ou à la
mitraillette c'est bien. Ça te donne pas
des capacités pour lire un bilan tu vois
c'est
si tu as les capacités de lire un bilan
que tu sais tirer la calnikov. Tu es
capable d'aller faire du renseignement
dans une salle de trading ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Ouais, c'est ça. Donc si tu veux, il y a
eu il y a eu ce problème. Bon, c'est
déjà euh un autre problème, c'est que en
France et là je crois qu'on a un vrai
problème de fond.
En France, on a un ministère de
l'économie et des finances qui est hyper
puissant, hein, puisqu'il a fusionné le
commerce extérieur, l'industrie, le
budget, il a il a tout. Bon, résultat,
comme il est hyper puissant, il contrôle
tout. et il veut que rien ne lui
échappe.
C'est pour ça que quand
Bruno Lemer quand il te dit "On va
détruire l'économie russe par exemple
par les sanctions, c'est parce que c'est
ces gars l'ont dit c'est bon mais ces
gars ils sont tous piégés dans leur
système. Il y a pas de contradiction si
tu veux. Ce qu'il faudrait c'est que il
y ait pas un ministère de l'écronomie
des finances, il faudrait un ministère
du commerce extérieur. Il y aurait eu un
ministère du commerce extérieur, un
ministère de l'industrie et un ministère
des finances. Je te garantis qu'ils
auraient pas dit ces choses-là et que
l'économie qu'on s'y serait intéressé.
Tu vois, c'est ça le commerce extérieur,
il servait à ça.
Tu sais le le tweet de Medvedef ?
Oui.
En réponse à Bruno Lemire.
Ouai. Bah oui, ça
donc Medvedev lui dit "Méfie-toi popole,
les guerres économiques ça finit par des
guerres normales."
Mais oui. Ah ben ça la guerre la guerre
et la continue assez closite ce qui
disait que la guerre est la continuation
de la politique par d'autres moyens.
Donc on a effectivement la guerre
économique hein c'est une guerre comme
une autre hein. Dans la guerre hybride
dont on parle maintenant tu sais la
guerre partout de manière. On a parlé de
la guerre numérique, on a parlé de la
guerre des énergies ou la guerre bon la
guerre économique proprement dite. On a
parlé de la guerre militaire, il y a
plein de formes de guerre. Il y a
l'influence hein. Bon, il y a plein de
formes de guerre et justement les grands
pays, c'est des pays qui les bons pays,
c'est ceux qui arrivent à gérer cet
ensemble là. Et visiblement, nous on n
pas su le gérer. Mais on n pas su le
gérer pas seulement dans le casadre
d'une guerre avec la Russie.
Reg, regarde la France. Je lisais
récemment une statistique, je crois
qu'on a perdu dans les deux ou trois
dernières années, 1600 plus de 700
entreprises ont été rachetées par des
sociétés étrangères. Bon, quand on sait
ce que ça représente au niveau de
l'emploi, quand on sait ça représente au
niveau de les ressources, hein,
savoir-faire
et savoir-faire, oui, il faut quand même
se poser des questions.
Est-ce qu'il y a des têtes qui ont roulé
par terre à cause de tout ça ? Est-ce
que tu as vu des têtes rouler ? Moi je
c'est le grand problème. Le problème
c'est que en personne n'est coupable.
Ça c'est un des problèmes qu'on
responsable ou coupable c'est très
important la différence.
Ah bah il y avait il y avait un ministre
célèbre qui avait dit c'est madame du
Georgina Dufois à l'époque de Mitteran
qui avait dit jeétais responsable mais
pas coupable. Évidemment, c'est facile.
Bon euh non, dans la réalité euh c'est
vrai que dans notre pays euh on ne les
gens n'assument pas leurs
responsabilités, leurs erreurs.
C'est c'est une évidence, hein.
Tu dis tu parles de de Guerry Hybrid, je
parle de Guerry Hybrid, Ursula
Vanderleyen parle de Guerry Hybride et
qu'il faut que l'Europe se dote de
nouveaux savoir-faire.
Est-ce qu'elle est bête ? Est-ce qu'elle
est menteuse ou est-ce qu'elle connaît
pas ses équipes ? Parce que les Anglais
font de la guerre hybride en Europe.
Mais bien sûr,
depuis au minimum 2016.
Oui. Et même avant. Et même avant.
Ouais.
Je suis plus jeune que toi. Et
euh on les voit, on les repère. On a
d'ailleurs repéré l'ambassade anglaise
d'ailleurs le rattaché culturel qui nous
suivit sur Twitter. On a trouvé ça
extraordinaire.
Donc on lui a fait son pénédigré. On est
chez nous. Ouais.
Ah bah il faut pas nous provoquer. Puis
on est du genre relativement collant
surtout quand on cherche des crosses.
Ouais.
Petit euh on on était comme ça, on a
toujours été comme ça. Puis on est
relativement
tenace.
Oui. On lâche pas.
Non.
C'est comme le bulldog français. C'est
un peu comme le pit bull quand il te
goal, il est prognate et t'inquiète pas
et après il lâche plus.
Non non c'est la détermination. C'est
pas la force de la mâchoire.
Donc Ursula Vlen, la guerre hybride.
Nous les Français, on fait de la guerre
hybride. Bon, on est un peu des grosses
boues en Afrique quand on se fait
choper. Bon, il faut pas faire de French
bashing. Moi, je peux me permettre, je
suis français.
Ah oui, on a pas été bon en Afrique.
C'est vrai. On
n pas été bon
du tout.
Non. On se demande bien pourquoi. On a
rencontré quelques gars qui étaient
censés gérer le bordel. On les a écouté
au bout allez au bout d'une heure et
dem, on a commencé à se [__] de leur
gueule avec cette délicatesse qui nous
est très
Ouais,
ils l'ont mal pris mais bon le résultat
est là. C'est un peu quand on discute
avec la politique étrangère française,
on lui dit "Bon mo- 156 milliards de
balance commerciale, tu as un problème,
c'est soit tu es mauvais, soit tu es
mauvais."
Oui, mais tu as tout à fait raison.
Quand tu quand tu vois moi regarde quand
tu vois l'Italie qui est 3e ou 4e
puissance mondiale au niveau de la
balance commerce extérieure
d'exportation et que nous à côté on est
on tous les ans on est en perte bon au
lieu de se dire on a un problème on
parle pas on dit ah bah non mais cette
année ça pas ça s'est pas amélioré mais
oh posons-nous la question comment se
fait-il qu'on ne soit pas capable
d'avoir une balance du commerce hein
développée et on et pourquoi on prend
pas toutes les mesures pour le faire.
On a peut-être pas les répond attends
mais parce que les lois Bruxelles et
machin on revient pourquoi je te dis ça
? parce qu'on revient à Bruxelles. En
définitive, on s'aperçoit que Bruxelles
a dérivé par rapport à ce que c'était au
départ, c'est clair. Et en particulier,
je pense que madame Banderleyan est et
on verra dans l'histoire plus tard que
elle est celle qui a certainement une de
celles qui a dérivé le plus par rapport
aux idées originelles et au traités
parce qu'elle ne respecte pas le traité.
Tu vois, par exemple, la défense hein,
sur le plan de la défense, la défense
c'est régalien. jamais dans l'histoire
de selon les les accords hein au niveau
de la au niveau de de l'Europe, la
défense est un problème qui ne peut être
réglé directement que par les États et
chacun pour soi. Bon et ben là, elle est
en train d'essayer de regrouper le gen
de la défense. Déjà que le reste marche
pas, c'est pas la peine en plus de nous
mettre la défense.
Revenons sur la guerre hybride et ça met
connaissance du sujet et toute cette
bande de crétins qu'on peut écouter à la
télé. Bon, il y en a certains des bons,
mais on trouve que la majeure partie
soit ils pipotent, soit ils font de la
guerre hybride à base de source
Wikipédia ou ils font du téléphone arabe
pour faire les C'est très rigolo.
Oui, mais je crois mais attends, mais tu
viens de dire tu viens de dire une chose
importante parce qu'il y a pas il y a
les experts mais il y a aussi souvent
des journalistes hein qui sont comme ça.
Des quoi ? C'est quoi
s'appelle ? Des journalistes, tu sais,
c'est des gens qui font des articles ou
qui dictent des trucs. Bon et ben dedans
tu par certains, pas tous hein, mais
certains qu'est-ce comment ils font ? Le
rédacteur en chef leur dit "Dis donc, tu
as vu la la le flash AFP là, j'ai besoin
d'un papier de 15 lignes ou d'une
intervention télé de 5 lignes de de 5
minutes sur tel sujet." Le gars, il
connaît pas. Donc qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Parce qu'aujourd'hui la plupart du
journalistes sont pas spécialisés, hein.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il va sur
Wikipédia, il va sur machin, il va
chercher des trucs, hein, et il va faire
un article qui est pas mauvais avec les
éléments qu'il a eu. Le problème, c'est
que si les éléments sont faux, ben
évidemment tout est faussé. Si les
éléments sont faux, mais ils sont faux
parce qu'une puissance étrangère
alliée de la France dire, mais j'allais
te le dire, souvent les éléments sont
faux parce qu'il y a eu des éléments mis
dans les analyses pas ou dans les dans
les dans les dossiers, les publications
et autres. Il y a des analyses qui sont
mises dans le but de tromper et de faire
penser autrement.
d'ailleurs peut peutquer aussi les
intelligences artificielles, mais on
reviendra sur ce sujet en 2026 où on est
en train de préparer ça.
Mais on est en plein on est en plein d
hein,
on spoile pas notre programme de
Attends aujourd'hui l'intelligence
artificielle c'est très bien va faire un
très bien de faire quelque chose
làdessus parce que ça vient vraiment un
problème si tu veux hein et puis ça peut
tu peux créer ce qu'on appelle des
avatars dans le métier c'est des fausses
personnes par exemple
clones d'Emmanuel Macron
les clones Oui. cl de qui tu voudras, tu
peux en créer des milliers. Ces milliers
vont parler sur et vont vivre hein sur
sur Facebook, sur internet, sur ce que
tu voudras, enfin dans partout hein. Ils
vont vivre, ils vont faire des
commentaires, ils vont mettre des images
et puis tout ça c'est dans le but
de de pousser de pousser tout le monde
pour aller dans un sens. Revenons dans
la guerre hybride. Ursulau la vente
d'Orleyenne et euh ça la bande de de
fierfé qui tourne autour de ce sujet-là.
La majeure partie du temps euh on les
regarde euh
avec bienveillance parce que ils
connaissent rien mais ils vendent
beaucoup de livres ou ils font beaucoup
de confiance.
Nous, on est sur le terrain
depuis 15 ans H
activement.
On a infiltré salle de rédaction, on a
été voir comment il fonctionnait. On a
été formé par un grand journaliste qui
nous a raconté toutes les combines du my
Vous connaissez toutes les combines,
c'est clair.
Leurs petits arrangements, comment il
désingue un adversaire politique et j'en
passe des meilleurs et j'en passé des
meilleurs. Et on a vu se déployer ça sur
internet et puis un jour, on a été pris
dans leur filet.
Euh, ils ont essayé de nous ravager
notre réputation, utiliser n'importequel
et ainsi de suite
et on le savait, on avait anticipé.
OK, c'est clair.
Et donc, on a tendu des pièges, des
honeypts, des pots à miel, des on
appelle ça des trappes à
à stupid.
Ouais. Oui, très
et puis on les laisse tomber dedans. Ils
se complaent dedans comme des petits
porcelets se roulant dans la boue et se
flattant à manger dans leur houge
subventionné avec nos impôts.
Ça va faire partie d'un chapitre dans
notre livre où on raconte la réalité
vraie de notre expérience vraie sourcée
avec même des photos et même des images
à colorier
pour démasquer cette bande parce que
c'est une bande. Les services de
renseignement français de la DGSI,
ils sont pas censés protéger les
Français contre des crétins. Alors la
DGSI, il nous connaissent bien la DGSE
aussi parce que le patron a changé. Il
est passé de la DGSI à la DGSE
et comme il il est passé à la DGSI, il
était content de sentir l'odeur de
Cyprene qui avait au bout de notre
gland.
Ouais. Et désolé pour le langage
châtier, mais on aime bien se faire
sentir le le le bout de l'urêtre.
Ouais. Euh euh c'est très agréable
là-dessus, surtout quand c'est payé avec
nos impôts. Là-dessus, on se pose la
question, on ne chiffre plus, on leur
laisse un boulevard pour essayer de de
se rassurer. Comment il n'identifie pas
des puissances étrangères faisant du
lobbing ou de la pression sur notre
territoire contre les intérêts de notre
nation ?
Alors c'est qu'il y a tu as tu as deux
choses. D'abord les pays qui sont amis.
On a pas d'amis.
Ou quoi ? Non mais c'est les pays qui
sont amis. Donc on appelle amis sont des
pays qui pratiquent les mêmes les mêmes
choses que les autres chez nous. Mais tu
remarqueras que on n parle jamais.
Les Américains par exemple, ce sont nos
alliés, ce sont nos amis. Bon, n'hésite
pas à attaquer à faire à faire des
actions en France dans différents
domaines, en guerre hybride, en guerre
d'influence, en guerre économique, enfin
dans tous les domaines. Bon, on le sait.
Est-ce que tu as vu ? C'est rarissime.
Rarissime. Moi, le dernier que j'ai
entendu, c'était Pasquais qui en avait
fait partir 7 ou H, hein. Des c'est des
des gens de la CIA américaine il y a il
y a pas quoi il y a 20 ans 30 ans.
Tu te rappelles ce qu' a dit Hollande ?
Ce qu' a fait Hollande ? Ouais.
C'était risible. Ouais mais oui mais il
y en a pas il y a tu n'y as pas beaucoup
si tu veux on on ose faire ça avec des
amis. Or les amis les anglais les
Américains, les Allemands, tous ceux qui
sont autour de nous font pas de cadeau
et on dit rien. Alors après, il y a ceux
qui sont considérés comme nos ennemis.
Alors la Chine, la Russie, alors là, on
en parle, on en parle et mais ça je
dirais que ça
on met pas enfin on quand ça tu sais
c'est je vais citer une statistique qui
est très vieille hein, elle date d'il y
a 15 ans donc tu vois c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui c'était les renseignements
généraux avant que Sarkozy les
détruisent la dernière la dernière
année.
Attends, on rentre dans le détail.
Oui.
Sur la destruction. Oui.
Tu veux tu veux rentrer dans les tails
ou tu
si on peut on peut on peut on peut Bon
bah si tu veux
les renseignements généraux étaient une
avait était une petite merveille dans
dans le système français il faut le dire
parce que c'est là hein où ils c'est
c'est des gens qui infiltraient les
réseaux terroristes. C'est des gens qui
infiltraient tous les tous les tout ce
qui était mauvais pour la France
politiquement économiquement. C'est eux
ceux qui allaient informer les
entreprises des problèmes qu'il
pouvaient y avoir. C'était eux. C'était
eux qui étaient au cœur du système. Bon,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Le président
de la République les a pris en grippe
parce que les enquêtes des
renseignements généraux faisaient
apparaître certaines choses que le
politique ne voulait pas qu'on sache.
Parle de quoi ? De caisse noire, de
valise de billet.
de combine de caiss de machin et alors
le le président a pris ça en il a dit je
dissou les RG et comment il a fait il a
dit on va on va créer la DGSI en
fusionnant la DST et l' RG et il a mis à
la tête Bernard Squarcini qui était un
de ses amis hein qui était un ancien DRG
mais qui a joué la carte DST contre les
RG. Pourquoi ? Parce que le patron des
RG qui s'appelait Yve Bertrand était
détesté par le pouvoir parce qu'il
savait trop de choses.
Il savait énormément de choses si tu
veux évidemment. Il avait des oreilles
qui traînaient partout donc il savait
tout et ça c'était insupportable pour
certains. C'était insupportable. Donc on
a fait l'erreur de supprimer les RG et
du coup on a perdu toute cette capacité
d'information.
Et quand on a passé, on a on a fusionné
si tu veux RG quand qui ont été
vraiment vidés de leur substances et
DST, ça n'a pas bien marché au départ.
Ça a même mal marché pendant très
longtemps. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on a
perdu les réseaux d'informateur.
Parce que quand tu as un officier
traitant, un gars de la DRG, un officier
de l'G, bon, il avait des contacts.
C'est lui qui avait infiltré des gens un
peu partout. où il y avait des contacts
un peu partout. Le type, on l'enlève, on
lui dit "Vous, c'est fini, on vous
envoie casser les cailloux à tel
endroit, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?" Ben,
il y a plus de il y a plus
d'information. Et la France a été
pendant un certain nombre d'années sans
information.
C'est très grave ce que je te dis. C'est
vrai et c'est vrai pendant un certain
nombre d'années. Alors après bien sûr ce
sont des professionnels, il peu à peu ça
s'est reconstruit, ça se reconstruit
aujourd'hui hein. Mais c'est tellement
vrai ce que je te dis qu'il a fallu
qu'on crée un nouveau service qui
s'appelle le service le STRC,
hein, euh service territorial de
renseignement,
hein, pour recouvrir une partie de ce
que faisait les RG que ne faisait pas la
DGSI. Donc si tu veux, on a cette
création nouvelle à perturbé tout le
système pendant 10 ans.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses qu'on est
ressigné avec pasir technologie
américaine ? C'était caché parce que
c'est je crois je crois que on a signé
avec eux à partir de 2016.
Oui. Oui.
On vient de ressigner.
On a ressigné. Qu'est-ce que tu en
penses en terme de souveraineté, de
dépendance ? ralentir si tu veux, c'est
une création américaine financée par la
DARPA. L'équivalent de la DGA française.
La DARPA c'est la délégation générale de
l'armement en France. Aux États-Unis,
c'est la DARPA et la DARPA financé quand
même on a ils ont mis alors on dit 1
milliard et demi de dollars quand même
hein. C'est pas c'est pas un franc hein
et dans toute la période
d'investissement parce que c'était un
système totalement nouveau hein que que
les gens de Palenti ont réussi à faire.
et et c'est une société privée hein qui
a été aidée par l'État mais une société
privée américaine. Bon une fois que le
système s'est mis à marcher, mais bien
sûr tous les services américains tout le
monde l'a utilisé puisque
pas pour expliquer c'est un aspirateur
de données au niveau mondial dans tous
les domaines. C'est si tu veux pasir tu
lui dis ben on va parler je sais pas moi
de l'élevage des baleines au large de la
Nouvelle-Zélande et il te sort tout ce
qui existe comme information. dans le
monde sur l'élevage des baleines au
lorge de la Nouvelle-Zélande, tu vois,
il ils trouvent tout hein. Bon, c'est
ils sont vraiment très efficaces, hein.
Si
tu lui demandes la déclaration d'impôt
de ma gardienne.
Oui. Bah, par exemple, ah mais il est
capable de te retrouver des trucs en
disant il va peut-être pas, il va te
dire la gardienne al Madame Intel et là
il va dire à madame qui a fait c, qui a
fait ça, qui est allé là, qui a tel
numéro, qui a son compte là. Ils sont
capables de tout retrouver, hein.
Donc là, ils sont capables de dire à ma
à ma gardienne, par exemple, madame euh
comment s'appelle la bière portuga la la
la Sagresse. On va lui donner un faux
nom. Sagresse.
Oui.
Et euh
soit tu fais le pied de grue pour moi
dans ton immeuble, soit je vais te créer
des problèmes parce que je connais
toutes les finances de ton oncle qui
Non. Alors, c'est pas ça, c'est pas
Palentir. Palentir, il va recueillir des
informations si tu veux, il va te les
donner. Tu vas demander des informations
hein. Tu dis par exemple vrai
information sur ils vont te les donner.
Alors il y a pas l'entier, il y en a
d'autres hein. Les Israéliens ils ont
des trucs aussi comme ça.
Tu as testé le français
hein ? Non. Alors il y a une société
française qui essaie actuellement
qui commence par un paix. C'est ça.
Oui c'est ça.
Ouais
hein. On je sais pas si on peut la citer
ou pas. On peut pas la citer. Est-ce que
tu as testé leur bordel avec les
assurances les
alors cette société française elle est
en train d'essayer de faire un palentir
à la française mais elle a un vrai
problème parce que palentir a déjà signé
bien sûr depuis ça bien en avance hein
avec quantité de sociétés en France et
l'État puisque la DGSI travaille avec
Palentir et il y a quelques souours hein
je crois ils viennent de ressigner de
nouveau avec Palentir donc Pu pour 4 ans
ou 5 ans donc pendant ce temps-là ben
Ceux qui veulent un jour avoir le
marché, ben ils ont rien. Donc c'est
très dur, tu vois.
Surtout quand tu as des boîtes
françaises qui peuvent faire
le boulot.
Exement. Mais seulement il pour que ce
soit des boîtes françaises, il faut si
tu veux que l'État français à un moment
donné tape le point sur la table. Alors
Palentir bien sûr, si tu écoutes les
vendeurs de Palentir, ils vont te dire
eux, ils disent "Mais nous c'est
parfait, tout est secret, chacun est
garanti, chacun est protégé." Bon, il
faut être sérieux. C'est pas vrai. C'est
pas vrai. Tout le monde connaît comment
marchent les sociétés dans les sociétés
surtout de recherche d'information. Tu
peux mettre une dérivation et pour
donner l'information à d'autres. Alors,
on va dire c'est pas chez nous, on est
tout à fait clair, mais je rappelle
qu'aux États-Unis, les services de
renseignement ont le droit de consulter
sans que le juge y donner l'autorisation
tous les dossiers de toutes les
entreprises à partir du moment où elles
ne sont pas américaines.
Et en général, si elles font plus de 5
ou de 20 millions d'euros, ça les
intéresse encore plus.
Il faut envoyer Brigitte Macron taper
sur le du point sur la table. Je suis
sûr qu'elle sait très très bien faire
ça. Euh, on change de sujet. Oui,
Stéphan Séjourné, notre idole, notre
muse intellectuel dans la diplomatie
française et européenne.
Ouais.
Il il devait partir au Brésil pour
prendre une mine et puis bon euh les
Américains étaient arrivés 3 jours
avant, ils ont tout racheté et Stéphan
séjourné, il est reparti bredouille.
C'est la faute à qui ? C'est la faute à
nos services de renseignement qui ont
pas prévenu Stéphane séjourné que bon,
il va pas prendre sa mine. C'est la
c'est la il y a déjà c'est la faute
d'abord du ministère des affaires
étrangères qui quand même devrait savoir
les gens du ministère qui sont en poste
en au Brésil doivent savoir ce qui se
passe quand même. Déjà eux devraient
dire attention il va y avoir des
difficultés ou quelque chose parce que
on fait pas venir on fait pas venir un
personnage un ministre un personnage
important. notre muse.
Bah oui oui si tu veux hein. Euh on peut
pas la faire venir si il y a un risque
effectivement qu'on qu'on aboutisse à
rien. Tu me diras quand on voit ce qui
vient de se passer en Chine c'est pas
mieux hein.
Tu parles de l'avant ou de l'après
en Chine ? L'après était quand même
beaucoup plus constillant. C'est c'est
bon, c'est pareil hein.
Donc alors je je termine ma phrase.
C'est la faute des services de
renseignement, c'est la faute du qu
d'orsais ou c'est la faute que il y a la
faute
les services de renseignement
visiblement n'avait pas d'information je
pense sinon il les aurait transmises.
La question alors la deuxième question
que qui est sousjacente si tu veux c'est
entre les deux est bonne et que ça passe
non
je suis quand même beaucoup plus possédé
par le démon que toi.
Ouais. Est-ce que c'est pas du fait que
notre ministre, notre mus, notre apolon
intellectuel de la diplomatie avait
peut-être discuté avec des copains sur
des messageries pas du tout sécurisées
et que où son ministère ou ses ses
groupies qui bossent avec avait
peut-être discuté ou les Américains
comme par hasard avaient des oreilles ou
un nez ou des yeux qui se baladaient.
Alors ça là c'est un autre domaine. Là
on parlait on parlait des failles
françaises si tu veux avec le K d'Os on
parlait avec le KO on parlait également
avec bon les services hein.
Mais alors il y a il y a un autre volet
qui tout à fait raison de le dire, c'est
que il peut y avoir aussi des politiques
qui sont n'ont pas compris
dans la guerre moderne, la guerre
économique moderne, la guerre hybride
moderne que ils sont ils font partie du
problème et qu' peuvent être écoutés,
ils peuvent être manipulés, on peut leur
faire de mauvais coup et ainsi de suite.
Et ça ça arrive tout le temps si tu
veux. Et ça ça peut avoir des
conséquences. Alors si les conséquences
sont sont nombreuses si mais c'est vrai
que si par exemple tu parles sur un
téléphone non sécurisé de choses qui
sont secrètes, bah tu as une chance que
quelqu'un l'écoute et si ça et peut
avoir de mauvaises surprises après.
C'est ça. Mais les Tu sais,
tu as suivi Pegasus
hein ?
Tu as suivi Pegasus ? Oui.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que tu penses
que le seul français qui se trouvait au
bord, c'était une de nos taupes ou
c'était leur idiot utile
ou c'était simplement un touriste qui
voulait un peu de blé mon
alors en tout cas réseau utile. Non.
Donc on l'a sur les
rectification. Tu es plus possédé par le
démon que moi.
Ouais. Non c'est dans ce nom réseau
utile. Non malheureusement non
non. Je pense que si tu veux euh
les les gens, on disait tout à l'heure,
d'une part, tu es dans le dans le monde
des affaires, tu as des gens qui sont tu
as plusieurs types de personnes. Tu as
ceux qui sont euh qui ont une envie d'
envie de gagner beaucoup d'argent,
surtout maintenant, hein. Et très
Qu'est-ce que tu entends ? C'est la
cupidité, la vénalité, c'est quoi ?
Oui, c'est beaucoup la cupidité si tu
veux. C'est puis le fait qu'on les a mal
habitué si tu veux. Aujourd'hui,
aujourd'hui tu as des gens qui peuvent
gagner énormément d'argent. Euh parle
les trait regarde les gens des banques
d'affaires, les commissions par tu
parles de ceux tu parles de ceux qui
cachent leurs commissions
à l'étranger.
À l'étranger
puisqueon sait qu'une partie très faible
est payée en France et puis tu sais
qu'il y a un accord qui fait que dans
les opérations de des banques
d'affaires, la plus grosse partie de la
commission est payée à l'étranger, ce
qui fait qu'il paye pas d'impôt en
France évidemment hein et que c'est pas
contrôlé. Donc tu ne sais pas ce qu'ils
ont dehors.
C'est un sacrilège.
Ah oui, donc c'est pas ça pose un vrai
problème. Mais
c'est un sacrilège ou une forfaiture ?
Alors pour moi alors pour personnel, moi
je considère c'est une forfaiture
parce que c'est pour moi c'est c'est
ballonnettes si tu veux hein. Si je peux
me faire je mets une parenthèse dans la
parenthèse dans la parenthèse je me fais
l'avocat du diable
mais il nous emmerde avec toutes ces
taxes ces cotisations sociales et en
plus pour un résultat qui est mauvais
autant les mettre mais il y a des gens
qui t'expliquent effectivement qui
trouvent normal hein totalement de
d'éviter de payer des impôts et ainsi de
suite et que bon ben c'est normal vu les
sommes hein et vu les taxations en
France il est normal que ça parte à
l'étranger. Ce qui est un peu gênant,
c'est que les gens quand des gens qui
disent ça sont des anciens
fonctionnaires des finances he et que là
tu te dis mais attends voilà des gens
qui chez quand il était aux finances ont
taxé tout le monde et te disent
froidement ah non mais nous on est en
dehors nous he nous on met notre argent
c'est c'est pas clair c'est pas clair et
c'est pas normal c'est pas acceptable
mais comment on a pu tu vois par cette
histoire de de laisser les de l'argent à
l'extérieur une partie des commissions à
l'extérieur moi Je demande mais comment
on peut laisser faire ça
hein ? J'en avais parlé à Marlex moi
avant avant qu'il soit qu'il disparaisse
et à son âme.
He ouais pas à son âme. J'en avais j'en
avais parlé de ça. Je vous dis vous
devriez vous qui êtes intéressé par tous
ces problèmes, vous devriez les
regarder.
Olivier était quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
et d'une bienveillance.
Il nous manque aussi. On a perdu
beaucoup de potes cette année. C'est une
une année difficile pour nous.
Euh revenons revenons à à au sujet du
renseignement, au sujet de les écoutes,
au sujet de la diplomatie. La diplomatie
française
h
du haut de
toi qui est un chaîne,
comment tu juges notre diplomatie, notre
quai d'Orset ? Tu prends ça pour une
bande d'arrivées qui ne connaissent pas
les dossiers ? Tu prends ça ?
Non, mais je pense que tu veux alors la
diplomatie
où est-ce qu'ils sont très bons ?
D'abord si tu veux, moi je une chose qui
est sûr, c'est que la diplomatie c'est
un métier.
Vocation,
c'est une vocation. Oui, c'est une
vocation et ça un métier. C'est que ça
s'apprend si tu veux. C'est compliqué
hein parce que quand tu faire de la
diplomatie par exemple, ça suppose de m
choses. Il faut que tu connaisses que
d'abord il faut que tu aimes les autres
à l'étranger. Tu vas dans un pays, il
faut pas dire je l'aime pas ou je veux
pas leur parler. Il faut dire, "J'aime
ce pays, je vais essayer de me pénétrer
de sa culture, de de sa langue, de tout
ou de les pénétrer un peu."
Ouais. Et et avec ça, tu vas à ce
moment-là les comprendre et tu vas
pouvoir faire des diplomaties. Parce
quand tu vas discuter avec les gens de
ce pays-là, comme tu es pénétré de leur
culture, que tu les connais, qu'ils
trouvent sympathiques parce que
justement tu fais l'effort d'être
12 kil de fromage, 12 kg de fromage
quand tu arrives avec du morbier, je
vais te dire. Oui mais oui mais attends
mais ça oui ce que tu dis tout à l'heure
hein et tu offres de bons produits et tu
racontes des histoires et tout
je les offre pas.
Oui tu dis je vais vous faire parler ce
soir.
Oui d'accord hein.
Il faut toujours être honnête. C'est
vrai hein. Mais donc tu vois c'est un
système qui marche bien. Alors le drame
c'est que
et pour ça il faut pour arriver
ambassadeur par exemple dans ce cadre-là
et ben tu grimpes les échelons et à
chaque échelon tu apprends des choses.
Est-ce que tu apprends des choses ou
est-ce que maintenant quand tu grimpes
les échelons, c'est parce que tu avales
des couleuvres.
Alors aujourd'hui tu avales des
couleuvres. C'est vrai ça, c'est vrai.
Mais mais le pire aussi c'est que la
plupart de la plupart sont nommés sans
connaître et tu veux aujourd'hui on a
cassé la diplomatie et maintenant ben un
gars qui est sous-préfet dans une
préfecture hein peut se retrouver
consulier conseiller ou ambassadeur
quelque part. Bon, je n'ai rien contre
le sous-préfet d'une petite d'une ville
de province, mais est-ce que ça le
prépare à être ambassadeur dans un pays
afri dans un pays aux îles Salomon ?
Bien sûr que non. Donc ça va être une
catastrophe. Sauf cas exceptionnel, ça
va être une catastrophe. Et c'est ça le
problème. Ils ont cassé la diplomatie
en quelques années, hein. Et alors quand
tu penses que la France était le deuxè
réseau de diplomatie dans le monde,
qu'on avait à travers l'Alliance
française le plus beau réseau de relais
si tu veux dans le monde pour parler de
la France et puis aussi pour avoir de
grandes oreilles he pour savoir ce qui
se passait. Bon et là on a réussi, on a
diminué le nombre des ambassades. On a
maintenant on nomme n'importe qui dans
les ambassades. Donc il y a plus de
spécialistes, hein. Et on a réduit les
alliances françaises. Donc si tu veux
présence à l'étranger, elle se réduit
comme une peau de chagrin. Et c'est ça,
ça c'est très grave parce que ça
contribue justement à la situation.
quand on parlait tout à l'heure. Alors,
parlait quand tu as tu vas un ministre
va partir dans un pays étranger et puis
il va arriver dans un pays et là le ben
il va trouver peut-être des gens dont
personne ne connaît vraiment le pays, ne
parle la langue. Et comment et où on va
là
et où on va ?
Euh public Sénat, suppression du corps
diplomatique de points. C'est le
massacre d'un outil que le monde entier
nous envie.
Mais c'est vrai
!
Damien Rognard, les républicains.
Mais mais tu as raison de Benah il a
tout à fait raison hein. Et il y a un
autre corps qui a été tué, celui des
préfets aussi hein. Alors après, tu
t'étonnes quand il y a un problème dans
une dans une préfecture hein, on dit "Ah
mais qu'est-ce que le préfet a mal géré
? Attends, le gars, il était peut-être
professeur avant à l'université ou il
était je sais pas moi, il faisait
quelque chose d'ailleurs ou diplomate.
Le type, il est pas fait pour gérer une
crise où il y a des manifestants et il
va pas il va pas gérer sa solide hein,
c'est clair en jouant avec les CRS, avec
tout le monde et tout. Non, ils savent
pas faire ça. C'est des métiers si tu
veux. Et la France, on on savait faire
ces métiers là, on les a saboté. Alors
après, on s'étonne, ça marche pas. Bah,
c'est normal.
Imagine l'armée, on parlait de l'armée,
hein. Si on disait maintenant, bah
attendez, le gars qui est sous-préfet ou
diplomate, il peut prendre le
commandement d'une compagnie ou d'une
d'un régiment puisque tout c'est la même
chose. Oh où on voit que c'est la même
chose
et c'est ça.
Vaut mieux des grandes oreilles ou une
grosse moustache ?
Ah bah alors le problème Oui. Du coup,
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qui est le
mieux pour savoir ce qui se passe ?
Effectivement quand il y a plus de
terrain est mauvais et ben tu prends des
grandes oreilles. Seulement les grandes
oreilles et tu l'as dit tout à l'heure,
elles peuvent pas être écouté aussi par
les autres et puis elles peuvent être
manipulé. Ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure,
tu peux avoir de fausses informations et
là alors là tu as tout faux,
tu vois. Mais regarde et on arrive à des
choses aberrentes. Tout à l'heure, on
parlait de la on parlait de la guerre en
Ukraine. Il y a une chose qui me fascine
moi, c'est j'écoutais un ministre récent
qui disait "Les pertes russes en Ukraine
sont colossales. Ils avancent mais à
quel prix ?" Bon ok question. Nous
savons tous maintenant que la guerre ils
la font en envoyant un ou deux types
d'un côté, un ou deux types de l'autre.
Avant on avancé par paquet de 30 ou 40.
Quand tu prenais une bombe, il y avait
15 morts ou 20 morts. On était dans des
tranchées, c'était pareil. Là, il se
déplace dans tous les sens et tout. Tu
crois qu'il y a autant de blessés de
mort toi ? Bien sûr que non. Et c'est
ça, c'est un des problèmes de cette
guerre, c'est que le nombre de blessés
et de morts a diminué
du fait des nouvelles techniques. Tu
vois,
ben non, on te dit les paères sont
épouvantables et ça prouve une
méconnaissance totale du sujet. Tu as
gardé des sources actives dans des
différents pays que tu as traité.
Des deux côtés, hein. Des deux côtés.
Tu as gardé des sources actives des deux
côtés. Ah oui, bien sûr.
Euh, on parle un petit peu d'objets
volant non identifié ou tu as des sujets
que on n pas parce que ça fait déjà 2
heur qu'on est euh en
On me rend pas compte de l'heure. Moi je
suis euh
écoute, nous on est au jus de raisin de
Bourgogne et donc
vous avez le jus de raisin de Bourgogne
qui vous renforme
et on t'a gardé un verre parce que
j'espère bien vous me gardez un verre
pour la suite. Je l'ai mérité hein.
Non non non pas maintenant.
J'ai un trou à gauche. Non toi tu es toi
tu as un gros trou. Et j'ai un trou à
droite aussi. Un gros trou. Il y en a un
très bien qui m'attend.
Et ouais et je le défends
lui déshydraté de raisin c'est sa grande
passion. C'est très rare d'ailleurs
qu'on le voit. Alors j'en profite, c'est
la dernière de l'année. Tu as parlé des
îles Salomon quand j'avais 14 ans.
J'ai monté une antenne de 14 de 13,50
sur le toit de ma grand-mère et le
premier
cuisseau que j'ai fait en Blu, c'était
avec les îles Salomon. Et pour être sûr
que le mec me racontait pas n'importe
quoi, je lui ai fait envoyer une carte
postale.
Ah bah tu vois, tu vois.
Et et ensuite, on est euh euh on est
tombé amoureux du film Contact parce
qu'il y a une petite fille qui mettait
des petites épingles sur la carte des
États-Unis en Floride.
Bah oui, ça a été un des lieux d'une des
grandes une des grandes batailles du la
bataille du Pacifique dans la dans la
deuxème guerre mondiale.
Ouais. On est bien parlé dans un micro à
cause de radio amateur. Voilà. C'est ça
a été un grand truc. Et d'ailleurs, on
remercie le ministère des armées de
l'époque
qui nous a aidé à maintenir notre
antenne contre le syndicat.
B tu vois, tu vois, ça c'est bien.
Ouais. Euh euh donc bon, parenthèse
fermée. Oui, on va parler d'OVNI,
phénomène OVNI, vous inquiétez pas les
gars.
Est-ce que tu as un autre sujet
géopolitique géol ?
Non, mais on a couvert beaucoup de
choses. On a parlé de beaucoup de
choses.
Tu vas revenir de toutes les façons.
J'aimerais bien pour la première fois.
Alors l'été dernier euh je suis descendu
dans le sud de la France rencontrer la
communauté autour de quelques petite
bière et on m'a demandé et d'ailleurs je
l'embrasse et je le salue de nous
intéresser aux objets volant identifiés
euh au pan euh pan euh le rapport comé
consulte un certain ou tout à fait
et d'ailleurs euh on embrasse l'hodn
parce qu'ils ont participé au rapport
cométa
absolument C'est eux qui ont été les
paires du rapport cométat. Ouais.
Et on embrasse la bibliothèque de la
gendarmerie qui se trouve en Sémarne.
Ouais.
Et et leur grande bienveillance quand on
était jeune et très turbulent et sans
papier pour aller lire dans leur
bibliothèque où on a toujours été
accueilli d'une façon très aimable avec
des gens très sympas et qui étaient très
contents de nous partager leur bouquins.
Revenons aux OVNIS. Euh tu en as déjà vu
un toi ?
Moi, j'ai j'ai jamais vu d' Mais par
contre, j'ai lu beaucoup de choses
là-dessus
parce que à partir du moment où je me
suis rendu compte que ça pouvait être un
vrai problème de sécurité nationale et
moi tu sais, je suis plutôt d'un jeune
homme du renseignement, un homme de
curieux, à la fois curieux mais un homme
de renseignement, un homme de la
défense,
patriote
et oui et et patriote. Et je me dis il
faut défendre, il faut regarder parce
que s'ils étaient agressifs, s'il nous
attaquaient, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Puisquon sait pas comment les arrêter,
on sait pas ce que c'est, on sait pas
comment les arrêter. Donc c'est ça ma le
départ de ma de ma démarche si tu veux,
c'est de se dire "Bon, on raconte plein
de choses,
oublions toutes les petites histoires,
les hommes verts, les petits machins et
tout ça." Non, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Est-ce que ça peut être dangereux ?
Est-ce que ça peut poser un problème de
sécurité nationale ? Et puis derrière un
deuxième problème, est-ce que en les
récupérant on pourrait pas faire
progresser la science parce qu'ils ont
visiblement des technique que nous nous
n'avons pas ? C'est ça si tu veux ma
pense mon système de pensée là-dessus
c'est
rétroingénierie.
Ah oui, mais alors justement la
rétroingénierie et si tu veux pour
parler de ça qui est un des éléments du
problème hein,
on constate depuis
depuis ouais depuis 15 20 ans, depuis
que les moyens techniques ont sont
améliorés considérablement, on
enregistre de plus en plus de deux
phénomènes non identifiés,
variés, hein, et avec tous les moyens
modernes, si tu veux. Donc on peut les
étudier beaucoup mieux qu'on pouvait les
faire il y a 20 ans ou il y a 30 ans. Et
les Américains par exemple, ils viennent
de créer il y a il y a 2 ans, ils ont
créé un organisme s'appelle Laarro qui
est chargé justement d'étudier tous les
cas qui sont identifiés aux États-Unis
et en 2 ans, il y en a eu 720 750 ou 751
enfin bon en gros qui ont été
identifiés. Tu as de l'eau juste à
gauche he si tu as besoin à gauche non
de verre d'eau. Il y a juste à gauche.
Non ça va non ça va ça va hein. Ils ont
alors ils ont ils ont identifié à peu
près 750 cas. Ils ont étudié tous les
cas al avec tous les moyens américains.
Ils ont mis le paquet et ils sont
arrivés à la fin. Et c'est ça où c'est
c'est fascinant. Ils disent dans 21 cas
on est incapable de dire ce que c'est.
On l'a vu, on l'a mesuré on a regardé et
on sait pas ce que c'est. On on peut pas
expliquer et c'est ça qui est
intéressant. Si c'est que nous avons
effectivement c'est confirmé
aujourd'hui, c'est sûr hein, il y a des
choses que nous ne comprenons pas, que
nous ne connaissons pas et qui qui se
promènent. Alors dans l'air, dans l'eau
aussi il y en a dans l'eau hein. Euh et
on sait pas ce que c'est.
Je peux me faire l'avocat du diable ?
Oui.
C'est les Chinois, c'est les
Nord-Coréens. Ah oui mais alors c'est ce
qu'on a mais c'est ce que tout le monde
avait pensé pendant un temps hein
pendant très longtemps quand tu parlais
d'ovni les les les spécialiste rigolaiit
en disant mais non attendez vous avez
vous rigoler c'est pas ça du tout c'est
des engins espion des U2 enfin des U2
américain c'est des engins espions
coréens chinois c'est des techniques
nouvelles qu'ils ont trouvé alors c'est
des drones qui ont été mis en place par
les par les tout le monde racontait des
trucs et puis qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est que les Amériques américain
avec l'affaire d'une autre ont commencé
à voir là on a eu des vraent des tout le
monde a pu voir là des des films hein
des films et puis des trucs sérieux
c'est pas de l'intelligence artificielle
hein c'est des films militaires pris par
des avions de chasse qui qui font la
chasse à deux engins non identifié et on
alors avec les caméras de bord avec tous
les systèmes de mesure hein et on entend
en plus les discussions des pilotes et
c'est pas des petits pilotes c'est pas
des petits lieutenants qui arrivent
C'est un une colonnelle de l'armée de
l'air en Allen de la Névie et c'est
quand même quelque chose une solide et
un lieutenant colonel qui est
instructeur. Donc si tu veux c'est des
gens qui connaissent le métier et ils te
disent "Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
? Mais comment c'est pas croyable ?
Regarde ce qu'ils font. Regarde ça
marche." Et on voit effectivement ces
engins qui d'une part s'arrêtent,
partent à 10000 km/h, se déplacent dans
tous les sens et puis un moment même ils
rentrent dans l'eau, ils ralentissent
pas sous l'eau, ce qui est quand même
incroyable. Ils ralentissent pas, ils
ressortent plus loin.
Il laissent pas de traîner,
hein.
Il laissent pas de traîner.
Il laissent pas de traîner. Il y a pas
de traîner. Il y a pas de Il y a pas non
plus d'eau d'eau autour. Donc alors là,
on se dit bon, il y a du plasma, enfin
c'est un déplacement dans le plasma mais
enfin là c'est des problèmes techniques
si tu veux des indalistes techniques.
Mais alors maintenant qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Et bien aux États-Uniss ont pris
le problème bras lecorp. Alors, c'est
très intéressant parce que euh Tulsie
Gabar qui est la la la patronne des
services de renseignement américain,
c'est j'arrive jamais à savoir c'est CIA
ou c'est euh FBI. CIA non, c'est pas tel
FBI. Nel, ça doit être CIA. Oui, elle
c'est elle qui elle couvre l'ensemble
des services, la vingtaine de services
américains. Bon, et elle a dit, elle
elle a parce qu'elle a été saisie par
des questions, elle a répondu en disant
"Oui, effectivement, on enquête parce
qu'il y a vraiment des trucs qu'on
comprend pas."
Bon, donc là, ils sont lancés si tu
veux. On a une commission à la chambre
des représentants avec une reprendante
qui s'appelle Luna qui est une ancienne
militaire hein et qui est elle aussi en
train de qui a lancé des auditions comme
on fait à Paris hein, des auditions en
quantité et qui en plus audition là-bas
a été voir les Russes pour leur dire et
et les Russes ont dit "Oui, c'est vrai
qu'on a aussi des problèmes. On a on a
et puis on sait que les Chinois aussi en
ont. Donc si tu veux, tout le monde
commence à se dire il y a quelque chose,
c'est sûr. Et à tel point que les aux
États-Unis, il y a toute une campagne
actuellement et même des prêts des des
pardon pas des des paris qui sont faits
euh sur internet pour savoir quand euh
Trump va dévoiler la vérité sur cette
histoire. Alors, il y a un film qui sort
là qui s'appelle Age of Discover qui
sort maintenant aux États-Unis qui
commence à dire où là on entend des
responsables de très haut niveau qui
disent "Oui, c'est vrai, il y en a et
puis il y a certains qui disent même
qu'on a récupéré des et là on va
peut-être en parler, on va récupérer des
moyens hein et peut-être même du des
parties biologiques." Enfin bon, du
chinois, non ?
Ouais, on va on va en parler parce que
ça c'est vraiment intéressant. Mais si
tu veux donc il y a une prise de
conscience générale. Alors nous quand on
parlait de ça il y a 20 ans, il y a 15
ans, on te disait e tu as abusé du
passiste. Alors moi comme je viens de
chicard, j'étais chericard à une époque,
ça étonné personne mais on disait
attends c'est tu sais les histoires de
Valençol qui a raconté un cinéas il y a
peu de temps. On disait bon attends non
les gars ils ont abusé du passiste. Non
non c'est très sérieux il y a pas c'est
pas une rigolade. Alors, je reviens
effectivement sur le qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'on sait à part le fait que oui,
maintenant tout le monde dit il y en a.
Quand on te dit il y en a, tout le monde
se dit si on pouvait en récupérer des
morceaux, ça serait formidable parce que
là, on pourrait comprendre un certain
nombre de choses. On pourrait comprendre
le moteur, on pourrait comprendre les
alliages qui font la composition.
Pourquoi ces engins ont des
caractéristiques de vol que nous sommes
incapables avec nos produits actuels de
faire hein ? Nous, on est incapable de
faire des engin qui changent de cap à
cette vitesse-là et tout. Ils exposeront
en volant. Ah,
c'est pas vrai.
Comment ça ?
Ben nous, on a Emmanuel Macron qui est
capable de vouloir fermer des des
centrales nucléaires et ensuite de
vouloir faire encore des centrales
nucles. C'est vrai que là, on a un
champion. C'est vrai qu'on a un
champion. Mais mais tu as si c'est vrai
aussi que si tu veux là tout le monde se
dit si on peut faire si on pouvait avoir
des élément pourrait faire ensuite de
l'analyse du rétroengineering et
pourquoi pas pouvoir faire des engins
chez nous qui ressembleraient ou qui
auraient qui utiliseraient certaines
caractéristiques techniques de ça. Alors
là, c'est très intéressant parce qu'il y
a eu un une levée du voile mais très
vite, très simple avec mais il s'appelle
avec un oui un lanceur d'alerte qui
s'appelle David Grush, un américain qui
a dit avant de se faire bloquer par sa
hiérarchie qui a dit oui effectivement
on a récupéré des morceaux d'engin
et je les ai vu et j'ai travaillé
dessus. Donc alors comme c'est à ce
moment-là, on rentre dans le secret
défense parce que tu te donnes bien que
quand les si tu récupères des morceaux,
le pays qui le fait, il le passe à ses
ingénieurs des grandes sociétés
aéronautiques ou autres et ils vont pas
dire ce qu'ils ont trouvé hein parce que
ils vont s'en servir pour avoir des plus
performants. Skunk skunkworks, ça te
parle ?
Oui. Oui.
51.
Oui,
vas-y, je te laisse continuer.
Alors, mais le dossier 51. Alors, c'est
intéressant si tu veux. passe de la base
la base souterraine dans
Oui. Oui, d'accord. Parce que là, il y a
aussi des choses à dire là-dessus, hein.
Euh mais ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant, c'est de voir que donc on
sait que les Américains, ils ont
récupéré des morceaux. Maintenant, on en
est sûr.
C'est qui on
dans des crashes si tu veux, des
c'est qui on
hein ?
C'est qui on ? On en est sûr.
Ah bah, on sait on sait on a dans les
dans les déclarations des uns ou des
autres hein. Oui, dans les déclarations,
on a eu ils ont confirmé qu'ils avaient.
Alors maintenant ce que tout le monde
dit c'est d'amener qu'est-ce que vous
avez trouvé ? Mais
on sent bien qu'il y a le secret défense
derrière et qui les gars ils veulent pas
raconter ce qu'ils ont trouvé parce que
ça certainement ils sont en train de
l'utiliser dans leur recherche pour le
spatial, pour l'aéronautique et autres.
Donc ils veulent pas trop, ils veulent
pas en parler pour le moment mais il y a
une forte pression et je pense qu'ils
vont lâcher quelque chose dans les dans
les mois qui viennent. Ils diront
quelque chose. Imagine quelle
répercussion sur les milieux religieux.
Si par exemple tu as le gouvernement
américain, alors certes de Trump ou d'un
autre
qui dit "Bon, c'était pas des bouts de
chinois, c'était des bouts d'autres
choses que de chez nous."
Oui. Ah ben bien sûr, mais on sait pas
comment on sait pas ce que c'est.
Alors si il dit c'était des bouts
d'autres choses de chez nous, comment
les milieux religieux vont réagir à ton
avis ? Ah ben c'est compliqué parce que
si tu veux il y a plein d'hypothèses
hein. Alors bien sûr il ceux qui disent
ils arrivent des exoplanètes du truc
mais alors là il faut résoudre le
problème comment ils ont pu arriver
jusqu'à chez nous. Bon alors là tu as
desun qui te disent c'est la alors il y
a les moteurs à gravitation il y a
d'autres qui disent les moteurs à
distorsion hein de l'univers. Enfin il y
a plein de choses plein d'hypothèses. On
en sait rien. On en sait rien pour le
moment. Mais c'est sûr par contre, c'est
que au niveau religieux, ça posera un
certain nombre de problèmes parce que ça
remet en cause un certain nombre de
choses. Mais d'un autre côté, alors si
tu vois tous les livres, tous les grands
livres religieux si tu veux he le celui
des des astèques, celui des incas, ce
des Indiens, partout dans le monde
entier, dans tous les cas de figure, tu
as un au début
il y a quelque chose quelqu'un ou un un
quelqu'un d'inconnu alors décrit de
manière un peu incroyable qui a amené
une révélation. Bah ça c'est lawaska.
Et oui et oui mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
que je te dise hein ? Alors c'est ça
donc si tu
connais Yawaska ?
Oui je connais. Ouais.
Tu as essayé ?
Non non j'ai pas essayé.
Ça va alors ?
J'ai pas essayé mais je connais le Non
si tu veux. Alors la question c'est ça
c'est on va découvrir un certain nombre
de choses, ça posera des vrais
problèmes. C'est aussi pour ça que les
Américains ont hésité à à lâcher
l'information ou les informations ils
hésitent parce qu'on se dit mais
qu'est-ce que ça va comme impact ? Parce
que certaines révélations peuvent
effectivement amener à se reposer de
vraies questions et
à déstabiliser tout tout ça.
Bah regarde hein,
déstabiliser notre pays du pay.
Ah bah tu peux déstabiliser mais les
gens déjà ils peuvent avoir peur en
disant mais attends chose qui arrivent
de l'extérieur, ils nous veulent du
bien, ils nous veulent du mal, on sait
pas.
Bon, tu as aussi la prise de conscience
par exemple que bon ben effectivement il
se passe quelque chose. Il y a c'est des
gens que ça nous dépasse si tu veux
hein. Regarde dans dans le dans le
cantique par exemple dans la physique
quantique on te dit on peut être à deux
endroits à la fois. Ça peut être une
explication en disant bah ils sont dans
un monde et nous dans un autre. Dans un
plan dans un plan de l'univers et nous
dans un autre. Et puis par moment où il
y a des passages des sasses. Bon il y a
plein d'hypothèses, on sait rien hein.
Alors moi comme je suis très factuel,
moi tout ça tout ça je suis je mets le
pied sur le frein. Je dis attendez moi
je veux voir hein. Je suis comme
Saint-Thomas, je veux voir. Mais mais
indiscutablement on avance. Alors les
Américains avancent beaucoup. Je pense
que les Chinois la presque sa avance
aussi beaucoup là-dessus. Il travaillent
dessus. Les Russes ont travaillé dessus
à une époque, on sait pas très bien où
ils en sont aujourd'hui, mais ils ont
travaillé dessus aussi.
Comment tu sais ça ? Alors, les Russes
sont là-dessus parce que quand alors là
au début quant à la chute du alors dans
les années 90 quand il y a eu la chute
du mur, les les chercheurs européens ou
américains sont allés en Russie pour
discuter avec les les ingénieurs et les
chercheurs russes dans les instituts et
ils les ont pillés,
faut le dire hein, parce que à l'époque
les Russes étaient très pauvres et les
autres ils arrivaient avec beaucoup
d'argent donc bah il récupéraient les
infos hein. Ils ont garde grand rockur
d'ailleurs.
Oui,
ils ont pris ça comme un viol. Euh s de
jeunes. Oui, mais pour les Russes
c'était ils ont gardé un mauvais
souvenir de ça hein. Et et le et ils ont
récupéré des infos et on s'est aperçu
que les Russes avaient travaillé sur un
certain nombre d'hypothèses
là-dessus. Donc s'il veut, ils se
posaient des questions mais depuis on
sait plus évidemment ce qu'ils ont fait.
Tu connais la ville de Corollef ?
Là non,
ça te parle pas ? Hm. Attends, mais
peut-être
ville secrète euh où il y avait que des
ingénieurs euh qui travaillaient sur le
programme spatial et donc les
Ah si, ça y est. Oui, oui, ça y est, ça
y est. Oui, oui. Tout à fait, tout à
fait. Ah oui mais là c'est c'était bah
oui parce que les Russes avaient des
villes secrètes. Ils ont eu plus en
avait plusieurs hein dans lesquels un
étranger pouvait pas rentrer, même un
russe qui avait pas les papiers et où
effectivement il travaillait à des
recherches extrêmement pointues dans des
domaines, on dirait très avancé hein.
Euh oui
très mignon
hein.
C'est très mignon.
Oui.
Corollef. Ah oui mais c'était un grand
ingénieur d'astronautique hein.
Oui et c'est très mignon. Bon, c'est
style soviétique mais je je je te
conseille si tu as lu les trucs sur la
guerre froide et ainsi de suite te
retrouver
en fait tu peux comprendre l'âme
d'un d'une démarche intellectuelle d'un
peuple qui se met en autarsie pour
Ah bon
combattre la guerre froide et tu le vois
dans le style de construction
alors tu sais qu'il y avait aussi alors
là là je parler pour le renseignement tu
sais qu'à côté de Moscou il y avait
aussi une ville qu'ils avaient
reconstitué une ville américaine qu'ils
avaient reconstitué où les gens qui
allaient partir en mission vers les pays
occidentaux et surtout vers l'Amérique
était formé pendant des mois et des
années et ils vivaient comme les
Américains et
on a fait une série comme ça qui
s'appelle The American
incroyable incroyable il complètement
préparé il vivaient ils savaient tout
ils suivaient les résultats de la
télévision américaine l'image de
baseball et autres pour qu'on puisse les
envoyer là-bas avec comme on dit
maintenant une légende hein qui soit
indestructible par rapport aux
Américains
et ça a très bien marché. Ils ont fait
des infiltrations magnifiques
sur des décennies d'ailleurs hein.
Ouais.
Et les mecs étaient en sous-marin
pendant des décennies.
Le plus important c'est une légende ou
ou l'honnêteté ?
Quel point de vue ?
Dans le point de vue quand tu vas aller
chercher une source, vaut mieux avoir
une légende et l'intoxiquer ou faut
simplement être honnête ?
Ah non, quand tu vas chercher une
source, tu peux la chercher en étant
officiellement et tu peux tu peux faire
le le faire de manière officielle. Euh,
tu peux aussi effectivement le tu le
fais avec une légende comme on dit,
c'est-à-dire sous fausse identité
quand tu en général tu fais du
clandestin. C'est-à-dire que tu n'es pas
toi-même sous ta propre identité, tu
fais une mission clandestine et dans
cette mission clandestine où là tu t'es
construit une légende pour être crédible
et autres, tu vas utiliser le fait que
personne ne peut t'identifier pour aller
récupérer des gens, les faire travailler
pour toi et s'il y a un problème de toi,
tu t'en vas et on pourra pas remonter
sur toi. Enfin, ça c'est la théorie
parce que ça devient de plus en plus
difficile aujourd'hui hein.
Pourquoi ?
Avec les moyens modernes. Si tu veux
avec les moyens modernes, tu laisses des
traces partout hein. Euh
pris le numéro 2 de la DGSE d' 7 ans.
Ah mais mais partout où tu s fait
remonter d'ailleurs par Jean-Marc Manac.
Je conseille son papier. Tu sais, on a
eu une formidable expérience de ça.
C'était quand les deux agents de du GRU
là qui on du des Russes qui ont fait
l'attaque contre Skripal en Angleterre
là Spripal était un agent russe qui
avait trahi au profit des Américains et
des Anglais.
Et a dans le cadre d'un échange entre
les Russes et les Américains, on a
échangé Scripal et quelques autres
contre des Russes qui avaient des prix
aux États-Unis, hein, des clandestins
russes aux États-Unis dont la fameuse
Anna Chapman là, la rousse incendiaire
2 [rires] Ah ouais,
je t'ai vu
et et et on Mais ce qui est intéressant,
tu vois, c'est dans l'affaire de Scripal
qui avait été où il lui ont mis un coup
de novoc de de poison
sur les poignet de sa voiture.
Non non, c'était pas dans la couture du
slip,
hein.
C'était pas les coutures de son slip.
Euh en gros oui. Mais mais ce qui est
intéressant de cette affaire là, si
c'est les anglais qui ont monté le truc,
c'est que on a pu c'est là où tu vois la
ce que c'est maintenant si tu veux.
Une fois qu'on a su que le malheureux
cripal, il avait failli mourir avec en
étant empoisonn avec sa fille.
Ils sont remontés par les caméras en
cherchant hein avec les caméras, les
franchissements de frontières et tout.
Ils sont remonter jusqu'aux deux gars et
on a eu les photos et tout. On voit les
deux gars se balader dans des villes
anglaises, se préparer et tout. Ils ont
identifié les deux agents russes.
Ensuite, ils sont remontés en Russie.
Pendant c'est pas facile, hein. Ils ont
identifié en Russie où ils étaient. Ils
avaient même leur numéro de voiture
personnelle, leur tout le et on a eu
leur nom, leur grade et tout. Donc si tu
veux, c'est devenu et bien sûr, ils
étaient sous légendes quand ils étaient
en Angleterre.
Quand on les a appelé quand il y avait
le confinement en Russie à cause du
Covid.
Oui.
Tu as suivi un peu ? Non.
Ah ben bien sûr.
C'était un mourir de rire.
Ouais, bien sûr, bien sûr. On est
d'accord.
Un avertissement ou c'était une
opération ratée ?
Je pense que c'est plus ça tient plus de
l'opération ratée que d'un
avertissement.
Revenons aux OVNI.
Oui.
Euh on on va on va Tiens, trouve-moi des
questions. J'en profite pour faire
remonter Ouais, on va parler de
Jean-Pierre Petit à fond. Big up. Euh je
demande au forum de voter sur les
questions qui les intéressent le plus.
Mettez des petits pouces en l'air. Euh
comme ça on va pouvoir id Non mais pas
un seul pouce. Euh oui, ça on va pouvoir
en parler. Enlève tes doigts de pardon,
je suis en train de discuter avec
réalisateur comme c'est Noël et que il a
bien travaillé. Euh
revenons aux OVNI. Imagine-toi,
ils sont en train de faire du
renseignement chez nous là.
Oui.
Parce que dès qu'on essaie de les
filmer, ils se barrent. Ils laissent le
moins de trace possible. Ils ont une
technologie qui leur permet euh
de regarder à gauche à droite. J'ai
écouté euh le fait que peut-être les
Américains auraient retrouvé des traces
biologique. H
h
et
moi comme toi, je me dis ils sont en
train soit de faire une visite à Toiri,
c'estd qu'ils sont en train de visiter
le zoau avec des maca qui avec des
petits bâtons
ça les fait rigoler. Bon des fois il y
en a un qui se plante parce qu'il se
prend un orage. Bon ils sont pas allés
le chercher.
pe de nous
ou ils sont en train de faire du
renseignement
ou les deux mon général
les deux mon général
hein
si tu veux il y a plein de questions. On
a eu par exemple ça si on a eu les les
les
Américains russes et les R les Russes
aussi. Il y a eu un moment, ça s'est
prouvé dans les deux cas, il y a eu un
OVNI qui est passé au-dessus d'une base
de missile, tu sais, et il est passé
au-dessus et tous les missiles ont été
déconnectés.
il pouvit plus on pouvit appuyer sur le
bouton, ça partait pas quoi. Alors ça a
fait peur à tout le monde parce qu'on a
dit mais attends ils sont s'ils sont
capables de déconnecter truc c'est très
grave. Bon ça c'était la première
interprétation. Après on s'est dit non
c'est peut-être plus compliqué que ça.
C'est peut-être simplement qu'il y avait
un rayonnement l'appareil l'ovni avait
un rayonnement magnétique ou autre
infrarouge va savoir très important et
c'est ça qui a déconnecté les choses en
bas possible. Mais tu vois, il y a des
questions qu'on se pose. Mais alors
effectivement dans ces cas-là, on se dit
"Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent ? Ils
viennent voir, ils viennent mesurer, ils
veulent nous donner des leçons." Bon,
pour le moment c'est assez irrationnel
si tu veux. Ce qu'on voit c'est ils
suivent effectivement des on les voit
dans des dans des endroits comme les
centrales nucléaires, mais il y a aussi
les drones sur les centrales nucléaires.
Si je veux, ça attire tout le monde les
centrales nucléaires. Alors, faud qu'il
faut se méfier hein. Il faut se méfier.
Base de sous-marin aussi, hein.
Ouais, les bases de sous-marins aussi.
Donc si tu veux, il y a il y a il y a
plein de questions, on sait pas en
réalité, on sait pas ce qu'ils veulent
euh mais de toute manière s'il se
promènent et qu'il regarde et c'est
qu'and même il voit des choses.
Alors dans quel but c'est encore autre
chose.
Il y avait une question où j'ai vu du
coin de l'œil droit Jean-Pierre Petit.
Donc je vais lire la question tout de
suite de Doc Doc. Est-ce possible que
les vitesses de déplacement soient
expliquées par la création d'une poche
spatiemporelle
entourant le vaisseau quit de la MHD ?
Alors la MHD mon pote c'est la MD
vous magnéto hydrodynamique. Donc je te
je t'ai juste lu la question on je veux
juste reprendre l'histoire de
Jean-Pierre Petit qui qui est quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire
avec un gros caractère. Attends attends
attends attends.
Oui.
Euh il y a 45 ou 50 ans, il découvre la
MHD.
Oui, absolument. crée un Cocorico les
gars. Euh, il crée euh il comprend euh
le bourlet que ce soit un bourlet de
gaz, un bourlet magnétique devant un
aéronef lui permet de pénétrer ce
liquide ou ce fluide d'une façon plus
importante.
Absolument.
Et le gars se fait intoxiquer,
il reçoit des petits courriers super
intéressants, il se dit "Les les OVNIS
me parlent, les gens de là-haut me
parlent."
Nous, on a analysé ça différemment. On a
analysé ça différemment. On s'est dit
Jean-Pierre Petit euh euh génie
se fait intoxiquer par les Américain
pour que les Américains récupèrent la
technologie, le fassent passer pour un
doux
un tout on va dire fou. Et comme ça
personne ne s'intéresse à cette
technologie.
On a été questionné quelques copains
sous-marinés,
on les a provoqué, on leur a dit "Bon,
ça te dérange pas trop d'avoir une
torpille philo, guidé alors que en face
de toi, autant les Russes que les
Américains ont de la MHD, c'estàdire
qu'il tirent comme des des des balles de
de fusil sous l'eau."
Et on a eu confirmation que à l'époque
la MHD existait sur les torpilles de
sous-marin.
Oui.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas remettre une
médaille à Jean-Pierre Petit ? Est-ce
qu'il faut peut-être s'intéresser un peu
plus à ce qui se passe ? Parce que les
missiles hypersoniques
peut-être qu'ils ont aussi des
Mais c'est lui hein.
Bah oui
que hyponique c'est lui hein. Alors en
plus il aime pas l'armement et autres.
Mais il faut la réalité. Les missiles
hypersoniques c'est lui qui a inspiré
ça. Les torpilles les torpilles à très
grande vitesse.
Perquilitation. Oui, c'est pareil. Non,
si ve et indiscutablement il a il a
découvert quelque chose à une époque.
Alors, le drame, c'est qu'en France, il
a pas été écouté comme toujours hein
parce que c'était tellement
révolutionnaire que on les autres ont
dit c'est pas vrai, il raconte des
histoires, hein. Et du coup, ben c'est
les Russes qui ont repris le truc et qui
l'ont développé. Et puis maintenant
c'est les Chinois qui l'ont développé et
maintenant c'est les Américains paniqués
qui disent "Eh les Chinois et les
Russes, ils ont des engins qu'on sait
plus arrêter, hypersonique, il faut
qu'on en ait aussi." Donc ils s'y
mettent. Donc donc si tu veux, voilà une
invention une de plus une invention
française qui a été qui va être utilisée
partout et chez nous ben on la on
commence à la redécouvrir. Ça c'est le
premier point. Le deuxième dans ce que
tu disais, c'est la question quand
effectivement Jean-Pierre Petit dit euh
moi je l'ai entendu aussi Jean-Pierre
Petit, je le connais, je l'ai entendu
dire "Ouais, les OVNIS enfin les gens me
parlent de là-haut." Euh c'est un peu si
tu veux comme les religieux quand ils te
disent les saints, ils ont eu ils ont
entendu des voix. Même Jean Dark, ils
ont entendu des voix, ils ont entendu
des voix. Euh attention, je pense que
souvent c'est un en définitive les gens
pensent que ça vient de l'extérieur mais
c'est quelque chose qui reçoivent à
l'intérieur une idée, une intuition qui
qui occupe leur leur cerveau et ça peut
arriver à tout le monde. Tu as des gens
qui te racontent que ils ont un jour ils
sont réveillés, ils avaient mis dans la
tête, ils l'ont mis en marche et ça
s'est révélé vrai.
Brudo Lemer a sauvé l'industrie
française. Mais justement, c'est pour ça
que si ve c'est pas Donc alors lui il
dit c'est que j'ai été inspiré par
là-haut. Bon moi je pense que c'est
surtout qu'il a eu une intuition géniale
dans sa tête et c'est déjà formidable he
c'est extraordinaire.
Après,
et le le volet suivant de l'affaire,
c'est de petit, hein, c'est que il a
alors et ça je pense qu' est très
intéressant, il a il a imaginé un autre
un système un système
avec qu'on appelle Janus système
Ouais. qui est qui lui te permet et qui
pense qu'il y a il y a une face enfin
avec une face simplifie hein une face
positive une face négative et donc selon
l'endroit où tu te trouves, tu es d'un
côté ou de l'autre et du coup ça remet
en cause la vitesse de la lumière, ça
remet en cause plein de choses hein,
c'est ça change tout. tu peux aller
beaucoup plus vite que la vitesse de la
lumière et ça ça répond à un certain
nombre de réalités d'aujourd'hui dont
les trous noir et tout ça. On a les
explications des trous noirs beaucoup
plus logiques que celles qui serontes
par la presse aujourd'hui et par la
science hein. Donc il est il a il est
très intéressant petit. Alors le
problème c'est qu'il a il a un mauvais
caractère qui part très vite dans plein
de choses et que donc et qu'il est vomi
par il est repoussé par tous les
scientifiques français. Mais c'est
dommage parce que je suis convaincu que
dans tout ce qu'il a sorti, il y a des
choses que les autres devraient étudier
parce que là il y a des clés pour le
futur. C'est indiscutable.
On prend l'exemple de Jean-Pierre Petit.
Euh euh il a il a un caractère difficile
ou ou peut être perçu comme avec un
caractère difficile.
Dans le renseignement,
on est censé tout filtrer.
Absolument.
On est censé s'intéresser y compris au
fêé qui laissent passer la lumière.
Oui, bien sûr.
Ou aux gens qui sont un peu turbulent
parce que un peu comme le bigle, tu vois
ce que c'est un bigle
qui sait pas chasser mais il est
tellement turbulent que il va finir par
lever une grosse pererie. H
est-ce que tu trouves pas qu'on se prive
de gens brillantissimes parce que on les
juge et que on passe à côté des
perdrieries, on passe à côté de
technologies de
hyper hyper intéressante parce que on
les juge, on les classe dans des
catégories où ils se font intoxiquer.
Mais mais tu as tout à fait alors je
suis totalement d'accord avec toi le
c'est un drame tu sais je vais te citer
moi c'est saxupéri hein dans dans le
petit prince c'est un livre j'aime
beaucoup et qui dit il faut garder son
âme d'enfant
si tu gardes l'esprit curieux si tu ne
rejettes pas les choses en disant mais
non ça c'est pas possible
si tu dis et si c'était vrai et si
c'était possible le simple fait de dire
et si c'était possible t'ouvre des
horizons insoupçonnés
Et le drame de la des scientifiques
actuels, de beaucoup de scientifiques
aujourd'hui, c'est qu'ils sont bardés de
certitude là où il devrait avoir un
doute constructif
et triangulé et sourcé.
Mais bien sûr,
toujours vérifié.
Et là, on revient au renseignement.
Revenons au sujet. Attends, tuas je vais
prendre mets les doigts parce que j'ai
un retour, j'ai je suis pas branché à la
terre. J'ai prê
le marsané, il est bon et le saucisson,
il est bon. Alors, vas-y, choisis les
questions. Choisis où il y a le plus de
pouces. Alors, j'arrive alors question
de Totoro. J'arrive juste dans le flux.
Est-ce que quelqu'un a déjà demandé son
analyse des suicides à la DGSI ?
Alors, je te je vais en profiter. On va
parler, tu me fais parler. Les suicidés
à la DGSI. à la DGSI, c'est des
policiers et les policiers se suicident
trop régulièrement avec leurs âmes de
service. Ils sont exposés à des stress
toute la journée. Ils sont pas ils sont
pas euh considérés à leur juste valeur.
Et le la proportion des suicides dans la
police est très importante et comme la
DGSI c'est des policiers, ils sont
exposés au même stress post-traumatique
ou au même phénomène de dépression.
Donc pas besoin je pense de chercher X
complot de X puissance qui les désing
dans les dans les
Quel est ton avis ?
Ah ben moi totalement c'est que c'est
que ce soi les policiers, les gendarmes
autres, ce sont des gens qui qui ont sur
lesquels pèse une grosse pression hein.
C'est dur hein c'est dur en plus quand
tout vent en plus dans certaines régions
de France dans certains villes de France
ils sont l'objet même d'agression de la
part de leurs concitoyens
leur hiérarchie
Oui. De leur hiérarchie aussi. Donc
quand tu as tu as décidé de te de servir
ton pays et que tu prends des coups de
partout, c'est pour des gens qui sont un
peu faibles, ça peut les déstabiliser
complètement et ça peut aboutir au
suicide. Ça c'est ça existe, c'est vrai,
hein. C'est c'est regrettable.
Dans le renseignement, tu es tu es tu es
passé avec des analyses qui à force de
s'en prendre plein la tête, à la force
d'étudier des trucs où il y a des
partout,
dans le renseignement extérieur, c'est
différent. dans le renseignement, c'est
un peu différent parce que c'est pas du
tout les mêmes, c'est pas le même
environnement si tu veux. Euh bon, quand
tu es clandestin, c'est autre chose,
hein. Puis en plus, il faut une force
morale. Pour être clandestin, il faut
avoir une force morale qui fait que tu
es pas candidat au suicide, hein. Un
clandestin, ça suicide pas, hein. C'est
clair.
C'est programmé.
Ouais. Ouais. Voilà. Donc si c'est c'est
autre chose, si tu veux. Et puis et
quand tu travailles dans les services de
renseignement extérieur, euh c'est pas
le même fonctionnement. Il n'empêche
quand même que tu as des gens qui sont
déstabilisés par leur hiérarchie, qui
sont déstabilisés par leurs collègues,
qui le harcèlement, les trucs, ça existe
partout, hein.
Reconnaissance
euh
la reconnaissance, il y en a pas tant
que ça effectivement. Tu as raison. Il y
a il y a beaucoup de gens qui quand ils
s'en vont à la fin euh sont un peu déçus
parce qu'ils pensent qu'on na pas
reconnu leur travail, leur vraie valeur.
Ils ont fait plein de choses, on l'a pas
reconnu. Et c'est vrai que alors dans
l'armée, on dit qu'on est récompensé en
la personne de ses chefs, hein. toujours
bon euh c'est valable partout mais enfin
non mais en plus c'est vrai que dans des
dans des services tu travailles de
manière discrète même clandestine tu
peux pas être récompensé comme celui qui
est sur la place publique tous les
jours. C'est clair donc c'est un peu
compliqué.
Question internet. Bonsoir monsieur
Juyet. Vous avez évoqué le couple star
des néoconservateurs Victoria Uand et
Robert Kagan. Oui,
ils vivent maintenant à Bruxelles. Je
demande à vérifier l'information
d'ailleurs.
Ils vivent maintenant à Bruxelles.
Est-ce que les néons conservateurs ont
fuit Trump vers l'Europe et que cela
explique le bellicisme européen ?
Euh, ça c'est une vraie question.
C'est une vraie question parce que
effectivement moi je me souviens
quelques années quand on a commencé à
voir ce mouvement en Europe
pro néoconservateur on s'est dit mais
ils sont en train d'infiltrer l'Europe
en avait pas en Europe hein c'était les
Américains qui étaient conservateurs et
effectivement peut se demander c'est une
question qu'il faut se poser si le fait
qu' leur leur influence a
considérablement diminué aux États-Unis
au profit d'autres groupes comme les
évangélistes comme enfin il y a d'autres
groupes
euh d'hiver qui ont pris de l'importance
à leur place et peut-être que ça les a
ça les a amené à se poser d'autres
questions et à ça les amené à se
déplacer. Donc oui effectivement le fait
par que Nuland qui est quand même
ancienne ancienne vice-ministre des
affaires étrangères américaines quand
même hein qu'elle se soit installée avec
Cagan en Europe, ça pose quand même
problème. Ça veut dire qu'elle se sent
pas bien aux États-Unis et Cagan non
plus.
L'Europe est tellement magnifique. Puis
Bruxelles c'est extraordinaire. Ah bah
Bruel c'est parfait pour
le parc la cambre la bière est
extraordinaire les Belges sont gén on
est devenu néoconservateur alors les
positions entre parenthèses les si on
regarde froidement hein les positions
françaises allemandes ou amé ou anglaise
sur l'Ukraine sont des positions de
néoconservateur
totalement
bien tu cherches une question avec des
bons petits pouces euh revenons.
néoconservateur
on va délayer un petit peu. Euh tu as
pas l'impression que notre élite
européenne a été bibronnée avec de
l'argent de néoconservateur pendant 15
20 ans h
que il s'attendait pas à ce que Trump
passe une deuxième fois parce que
ils font pas de renseignement aux
États-Unis, ils regardent pas les bonnes
les bons chiffres, ils se baladent pas
sur le terrain ou
et puis Trump est immunisé contre les
balles comme tu as pu le voir. Il a des
mouvements de tête qui lui par
Ah mais il a dit que Dieu était avec lui
hein. C'est
Ouais. Ouai le hasard aussi ça peut
Mais non c'est vrai c'est un coup de
chance incroyable en il aurait pas bougé
la tête il bouge la tête dans tous les
sens. Il aurait pas bougé de de 5 cm il
était il était mort
hein. C'est c'est incroyable l'histoire
de Trump hein. Ils l'ont loupé. Ils
l'ont loupé et puis après il attend je
sais pas je sais pas si l'enquête a
prouvé que c'est c'était des réseaux
derrière mais le gamin l'a loupé. Non
mais on trouvera rien. Il y a il y a un
gamin qui était absolument innocent qui
est monté sur un toit avec une carabine
hein et qui a tiré à 200 m avec une
précision diabolique. Bon à
200 m tu as déjà tiré à 200 m avec un
famas. Tu mets ça ou enfin c'est quand
même il a bien tiré hein.
Ouais non non mais non je pense que non
moi attends il faut pas faut arrêter de
rêver. Il y a pas quand tu as des
histoires comme ça, tu as quand même
allez moi je veux pas faire du
complotisme mais il a 90 chances sur 100
pour qu'il y a ce soit une opération qui
a été montée par un groupe. Alors quel
est le groupe ? Ça on sait pas comment
ça a été monté pour le moment. On en
sait rien hein.
Donc revenons à nos néocconservateurs
européens qui sont orphelins de la
maison mer
qui attendent peut-être que la maison
maire change d'ici. C'est quand ? C'est
quand les prochaines élections Mais
peut-être qu'ils espèrent alors
peut-être qu'ils espèrent aux États-Unis
que Trump sera battu vers la prochaine
élection présidentielle.
L'économie américaine va pas très bien.
Oui, mais il faut se méfier parce que je
pense qu'il va prendre plein de mesures
pour expliquer que les choses bon vont
mieux. Euh mais c'est vrai le problème
pour moi depuis le début, j'ai toujours
dit que euh le problème pour Trump c'est
qu'il réussissent les mid terme, hein,
les élections intermédiaires
américaines. S'il réussit les mid
termees, euh il a gagné et le prochain
président des États-Unis après ce sera
VZ, hein, puisque Marco Rubio a dit que
il se mettait derrière V.
Maintenant, si par contre il perd les
mid termees, alors là va se poser la
question, c'est est-ce qu'il risque pas
de perdre également les présidentiels
ensuite ? Et là, peut-être que ça peut
inspirer certains pour essayer de
revenir.
Est-ce que c'est Est-ce que tu penses
queon fait durer la guerre en Ukraine et
que les Européens freent des cas de fer
pour attendre ça ?
Non, parce qu'elle pourra pas durer
jusque-l
si tu veux. La guerre en Ukraine
aujourd'hui, comment on la bloque ? Va
on la continue. C'est parce que Zelenski
dit il n'est pas question que je cède
les provinces du Donbas aux Russes
ce qui est logique.
Mais bien sûr mais quand les Russes vont
avoir atteint la limite des provinces du
Dombas qu'ils auront conquis Cramator si
tu veux al ça va prendre 6 mois un an.
Bon ça mais ils y arriveront un jour à
ce moment-là ils diront bon ben on est
arrivé à nos objectifs de début de
campagne on arrête là c'est fini et on
discute plus puisque de toute manière on
a tout occupé.
J'ai j'ai une question purement
technique de de militaire, je dirais. Je
vois des experts sur la télé, dans ma
télé ou dans mon poste, ma boîte et imag
ça comme tu veux
où ils se foutent de la gueule des
Russes en disant "Mais ça fait 4 ans
bientôt que ils ont même pas pris 20 %
du territoire ukrainien. Ils ont perdu x
milliers et centaines de milliers ou
millions de morts et que ils s'épuisent
et queils savent pas faire la guerre".
Ainsi de suite. Je me pose la question.
Oui.
Pourquoi ils ont pas fait les Russes ?
Pourquoi ils ont pas fait la guerre la
guerre à l'américaine ? Pourquoi
pourquoi ils ont ils ont pas fait genre
je t'aplatie bien salement depuis parce
que les parce que les d'abord un les
Russes n'ont pas les mêmes tactiques
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale, on
le sait hein. Les Russes n'ont pas les
mêmes tactiques que les Américains. Il
essentiellement sur eux il y a
l'artillerie. Ce qu'on oublie toujours,
c'est que l'artillérique joue un rôle
essentiel chez les Russes alors que ça
n'existe pas dans les pays européens.
D'ailleurs, maintenant ça nous oblige à
repenser. On a vu avec les avec les
canons César que c'était bien utile
parce que justement en en dans la guerre
à l'Ukrainienne, ça compte donc il en
faut plus. Donc il y a les problèmes de
il y a les problèmes de l'artillerie.
Bon ça c'est un point sur lesquels les
Russes sont différents des autres mais
aussi les Russes ils ont pas beaucoup
ils sont pas riches, ils ont pas
beaucoup de moyens.
C'est il faut regarder le budget
américain de la défense, c'est 1
milliard de dollars. 1000 milliards de
dollars.
H OK, le budget des Chinois, c'est 300
330 milliards de dollars. En gros, 1/3,
c'est toujours en gros les les Chinois,
c'est un/ers du budget américain.
Tu peux t'arrêter ? Oui,
ton slip américain, il te coûte 20
dollars. Ton slip chinois, il te coûte 2
dollars.
Ah oui, mais bien sûr.
Donc moi le le le
Ah oui, mais je dommage, je te parle, tu
as tout à fait raison. Tu es tu quand je
te parle moi de des de des chiffres en
disant c'est 1/3 mais ça ne veut pas
dire qu'au niveau du coût d'achat et du
maintien c'est le même parce que chez
les Chinois ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
hein à tout point de vue. Donc si tu
veux quand ils font un/ers c'est
peut-être 50 % de de la du budget
américain au moins, hein. Donc ça on est
on est d'accord là-dessus hein.
Les Russes c'est 135 milliards
mais les Russes sont tout petits. Tu
pens exactement les Russes aujourd'hui
avec la guerre en gros à 130 30 135
milliards, ils étaient à 60 70 milliards
avant la guerre. Donc si tu veux, ils
ont augmenté avec la avec la guerre, ils
ont augmenté l'économie de guerre, c'est
ça hein. Où sont les retraites ?
Ah, ce sont les retraites là. Et ils ils
ont ils ont augmenté considérablement si
tu veux leur le budget militaire. Ils
l'ont bah quand même presque doublé
hein. Ils l'ont doublé mais presque
hein. Mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que 135 milliards
quand tu vois les Chinois et quand tu
vois les Américains ? Quand on me dit
alors on te dit et on te dit les
Européens les Européens bon tu as tu
cumules les Allemands il y a pas il y
avait pas grand-chose ils vont monter
ils vont faire 80 milliards ils
annoncent 80 milliards 800 milliards
pardon non 80 milliards pardon 80
milliards les français ça va être à 40
il plus de 500 milliards de dettes
levées sur les marchés nch
ouais voilà mais si tu veux quand tu
regardes l'Europe
actuelle elle représente à peu près le
même le même niveau avec les
investissement, ça va donner à peu près
le même niveau que la Russie actuelle,
pas plus hein,
sur les 6000 têtes nucléaires.
Euh
ouais, mais c'est c'est pour ça qu'il
faut il faut il faut raison garder, si
tu veux dans tout ça, il faut et les
Russes c'est pas une grande armée hein,
c'est pas ils ont pas On le voit bien la
plupart du matériel qu'ils utilisent un
matériel est obsolète hein.
On a dit ils ont eu des chars en
pagaille. C'est vrai, on les a mesuré he
les spécialistes ont mesuré chaque char
sur les photos des satellites et autres.
Bon, on te dit ils ont perdu demi ou je
sais pas combien. Oui, ce qu'on vrait
vraiment ajouter à côté c'est que les
chars qu'ils ont perdu, c'est des chars
qui dataient pratiquement de la deuxième
guerre mondiale, hein.
Ils ont été
mais ils avaient partout parce qu'ils
avaient ils avaient pas grand-chose.
Ils les ont recyclé en Ukraine.
Et oui, exactement. Ils ont recyclé tout
leur matériel, hein. Alors, on a vu
aussi de nouveaux matériels, on disait
tout à l'heure he ils ont testé de
nouveaux matériel, mais il y a beaucoup
de choses qui étaient dicté très bien
parce que la la Russie n'était pas un
pays riche, hein.
Si si les OVNIS nous regardent et que
c'est réellement une civilisation
différente de la nôtre, on donne quelle
image ? H
nous, l'humanité dans sa globalité, on a
des comportements béliqueux de prédation
comme des macaques qui se battent. pour
arrête de le rouge toi.
H est-ce que est-ce que on se b on se
continue par est-ce qu'on est archaïque
à ce point-là ou est-ce
où où est-ce que on va réussir à passer
à autre chose ? C'est-à-dire arrêter de
se faire la guerre, arrêter de se faire
la guerre économique, de claquer du fric
pour faire de la vo il faudrait C'est
vrai que l'idéal, on en rêve depuis
longtemps, hein. L'idéal c'est la paix,
hein. Euh, on se dit c'est quand même
idiot dans un dans une sur une planète
comme la nôtre qu'on soit tous en train
de se faire la guerre ou que
dans un certain nombre de coins du
monde, on se fasse la guerre. C'est
c'est absurde. Donc, si on pouvait
trouver les conditions de faire la paix,
ça serait quand même mieux. ou régler
les problèmes autrement que par la
guerre. Bien sûr.
Est-ce que sur le sujet OuNI, tu veux
rajouter quelque chose ou tu on referas
un spécial OVNI avec d'autres ? Tu nous
accompagnera ou est-ce que tu veux nous
parler d'un truc en particulier qui t'a
marqué ?
B non, je crois qu'on a on a couvert
beaucoup de choses quand même hein.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet qu'on a pas
couvert que tu souhaiterais aborder ?
Euh question internet. A-t-il des
nouvelles informations juridiques ou
entre parenthèses
sur des disparitions de Marlex et de DNC
?
Non non. Alors, j'ai pas moi j'ai pas de
j'ai on a on a on a dit effectivement
l'affaire des naissé c'est le suicide de
DNS interroge. Je suis très prudent
parce que dans ces histoires là on n'est
jamais sûr de rien. Et le suicide de
Marlex aussi hein, le suicide de DNS. Je
rappelle qu'il s'est suicidé avec une
carabine 22 van de long rive dans une
petite voiture en route de Savoie, hein.
Et alors selon ce qui se dit, mais il
faut être très prudent parce que moi
j'ai pas vu le PV de la gendarmerie,
hein. Il se dit que le fusil était à
côté de lui alors qu'il s'est tiré une
balle dans la ici hein sous le menton
hein en tenant son fusil comme ça. Quand
on se suicide avec un fusil, c'est comme
ça hein. On tient hein, on tient et on
tient le fusil et on appuie. Bon, donc
c'est assez étonnant, c'est que
normalement quand c'est comme ça, une
fois que vous avez pris la balle, vous
lâchez tout. Bon et donc le fusil est
dans une position. Or, visiblement, il
était pas en cette position là. Et le
deuxième chose, c'est qu'il y avait pas
d'empreinte semble-t-il, d'après ce
qu'il se dit, hein, il y avait pas
l'empreinte des mains de DNC sur le
fusil. Or quand vous êtes vous tirer
dessus mais et vous devez tenir le fusil
à deux mains, normalement on laisse des
empreintes. Donc ça c'est une une
question mais on a il y a eu des
demandes qui étaient faites par la par
la famille et par d'autres et les
journalistes aussi avec raison en disant
la gendarmerie dit ce qui s'est vraiment
passé. Est-ce que c'est vrai ? Est-ce
que c'est faux ? Parce que s'ils disent
mais non il y a les empreintes, le
fusil, bah le problème est réglé. Bon,
le sur Marlex, c'est aussi un truc très
étonnant parce que il s'est suicidé avec
la corde au coup. Il s'est pendu comme
vous savez, mais il s'est pendu euh avec
une corde qui le tenait par le coup,
mais il avait les pieds qui étaient
posés par terre.
Oui. Mais toi, tu as pas pensé que la
corde avait pu se détendre ?
Oui, mais attends, non, non, la corde
s'est pas détendue. En réalité, pour se
pour se suicider, il fallait qu'il plie
les genoux.
Moi, je suis un peu étonné de voir
quelqu'un qui se pend en pliant les
genoux parce que c'est d'habitude tu te
mets sur un tabouret puis tu jettes le
tabouret hein quand même c'est plus
facile. Donc il y a quand même il y a il
y a aussi des questions qui se posent.
Donc on a mais on n pas tous les
éléments si vous voulez.
Il avait peut-être pas le moral. Il peut
Ouais. Alors bon, on dit qu'il avait des
problèmes familiaux et qu'il était il
était très déçu, qu'il avait perdu son
ami. Enfin bon, on dit aussi,
on dit devoir voqu ça l'a tellement
déprimé que
voilà. Alors moi ce qu'on m'a dit par
contre il y a de jours là qui semblerait
quand même être assez étonnant. Attends
source carré cubique.
Oui, je dis il y a 2 jours pour les
conents sur Marlex de jours on m'a dit
que celui qui avait fait le livre avec
le dernier livre qui vient de paraître
après sa mort venait de se suicider
cette semaine.
Non.
Oui, c'est ce qu'on m'a dit. Alors, il
faut que je vérifie hein. Je sais pas
mais si c'est vrai
triangulaire.
Si c'est vrai, alors là par contre, ça
commence à poser un vrai problème parce
que c'est suspect.
Ça ressemble à gros rouve.
Oui, mais comme dit comme on dit dans
les je crois c'est dans les tontonf dans
les barbouses c'est blanc c'est je sais
plus si c'est bli ou lié ou ou un autre
qui disait ou Ventura qui disait un
barbu c'est un barbu deux barbu c'est
des barbus mais trois barbus c'est des
barbouses voilà c'est un peu pareil hein
un mort OK morts OK de suicides OK un
troisème suicide ça commence à faire
beaucoup
il y a il y a l'ancien ministre de la
défense allemand
il y a une vingtaine d'années On avait
une discussion avec lui. Euh, il y avait
à peu près le même raisonnement sur un
autre dossier. Euh, question internet.
Avec beaucoup de boost, tu as trouver
beaucoup de pouces ? Ça, il faut leur
obliger à se mettre des pouces. Donc,
s'il y a pas de pouces, cherche avec des
pouces. Euh, on arrive à la fin de notre
interview et il va nous chercher une
question avec beaucoup de pouces. Ça les
obligera à faire de l'intelligence
collaborative et horizontale pour
pouvoir se lire et se respecter. Allez,
faites monter les questions là.
Est-ce que tu as avant de nous laisser
le conseil pour les jeunes générations
et que je te passe la question euh
signature de Syerview conseillant des
livres trouvé la question toi ? Non.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à nous
conseiller pour notre communauté à lire
quelque chose d'important ? Et ça y est,
il a trouvé une question.
Alors bon moi si j'ai j'ai des livres
j'ai des livres à conseiller. Moi j'en a
Oui, il y en a plusieurs hein. Euh il y
a il y a plein de livres à conseiller
hein.
Bah à titre personnel, moi je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure, il y en a un que je lis
toujours, je lis souvent hein, c'est le
je relis souvent, c'est le Petit Prince
parce que je pense que il faut se forcer
euh régulièrement. Euh il faut éveiller
sa curiosité en euh il faut il faut se
remettre en cause hein. Et le petit
prince, c'est un bon moyen de se
remettre en cause intellectuellement,
hein. Voilà. Bon, ça c'est le premier.
Euh
il y a il y a un livre que j'ai lu
récemment que j'ai adoré mais c'est très
ça n'a rien à voir. Enfin si enfin ça
parle de la guerre hein euh c'est les
nageurs de combat italien. C'est un
livre d'un espagnol qui s'appelle Perez
Reveré qui est un grand auteur en en et
qui a écrit un livre qui s'appelle
l'italien et qui raconte l'histoire des
nageurs de combat italien qui
attaquaient à Algésiras les bateaux
anglais à Gibraltar
avec une histoire d'amour sympa à côté.
avec une espagnole et je trouve c'est
une belle histoire parce que c'est des
choses qu'on a oublié où je trouve que
ces gens-là ils avaient un courage fou
quand on voit quand il il écrit très
très bien comment ça se passe et tout et
il a repris des faits véritables he des
faits qui ont été recoupés de l'époque
et ça je trouvais que c'est un livre que
j'ai bien aimé moi. C'est oui c'est un
livre de repos hein. Il y a il y a un
troisème livre que je viens de de lire
et que là je peux vous dire, je suis
président d'un oui d'une association des
anciens des services de la secret de la
défense nationale et on fait un chaque
année on fait un prix hein et je vais
pas faire de la pub pour le bouquin mais
le bouquin est bon. Chaque année, on
donne un prix pour la l'intelligence
économique,
hein, le prix du roman d'espionnage,
mais vu par nous, hein. Et il y a un
livre qui vient vient de primé qui
s'appelle Mes chers alliés, qui est une
opération d'intelligence économique
faite par les Américains en France sur
des sociétés françaises et qui est
superbe parce que vraiment c'est à la
fois un roman hein mais en même temps
c'est top parce que c'est vraiment comme
ça que ça se passe.
Comment tu as dit ? Mes chers all qu aux
aux éditions quoi
? Alors il faut que je Ah bah là par
contre je vrais que je donne ça mais
dépiche-toi, fais ton travail. Je
pourrais te le donner. Non mais
t'inquiète
mes chers alliers, vous allez le trouver
hein sur
Et donc maintenant qu'on a de quoi lire
pour Noël,
voilà. Bah voilà, vous avez des livres
pour Noël que je vous conseille et
mais relisez alors pour moi hein,
relisez Saintxupéri hein.
Il faut relire Saintxupéri
c'est les trouvé la méchan allié. Euh
Gilbert Galerne.
C'est ça.
Cétait un ancien. Il avait eu le prix du
quai des orfers il y a quelques années
et il a fait maintenant il est basculé
dans autre chose et il c'est un très bon
bouquin.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable pour les gamins qui vont
être obligés d'aller faire la guerre
avec Macron ou avec les Anglais ou avec
les Allemands ou face à Poutine ou face
à quelqu'un d'autre.
Ah mais non, moi je pense que
on a on a parlé de beaucoup de choses
mais il faut il faut pas que nos que nos
auditeurs pensent que tout va mal et
c'est pas ça hein. Euh au contraire
hein, moi je pense que le monde est
plein d'opportunités
formidable. Formidable. Des opportunités
partout pour ceux qui savent les
chercher. Mais il y a mais pour ça il
faut plusieurs choses. D'abord il faut
oublier le principe de précaution à la
française. Il faut savoir prendre des
risques. He tu connais ça ? Il faut
savoir prendre des risques, hein. Ça
c'est important. Prendre des risques, il
faut oser
parce qu'il faut il faut savoir et et il
faut il faut se dire que si ça ne marche
pas chez soi, il faut pas hésiter à
aller ailleurs.
Le monde est vaste pour les jeunes, la
jeune génération. Si l'Europe est en
train de se planter, tous les autres
continents du monde sont en train de
bouger à la hausse. Alors, si ça marche
pas chez vous, ben allez voir ailleurs
et vous trouverez des endroits et avec
l'intelligence économique, puisque moi
j'en j'en fais pas mal, hein, il y a il
suffit de regarder les zones du monde
qui vous plaisent pour des raisons de
culture, d'amitié, de langue ou autre et
puis on trouve des coins formidables. On
peut on peut développer plein de choses
et donc s'en sortir parfaitement
et revenir et défendre le pays
et revenir après défendre le pays dans
de bonnes conditions ayant réussi
convenablement ailleurs ce qu'on a pas
pu faire au départ chez soi. Alain
Juillet. Merci.
Merci de m'avoir invité surtout.
[musique]